the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
opening preparation is out the window at
chess 9lx in St Louis with randomized
back ranks nullifying standard Theory
players must rely on their Ingenuity and
creativity to find success luckily
inspiration was abundant with 12 of 15
games ending with decisive results in
such a combative field two wins wasn't
enough to claim the top spot Perfection
was required and Ian defamiyachi
delivered going three for three to nap
the early lead he's off to an excellent
start can he keep the streak alive day
two of can't miss chess coming up next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back everybody to the second day
of Chess 9lx action it's been a
fantastic start of this tournament and
today we're waiting for more Thrills and
Spills let's go to the studio and start
this exciting action with yaser and
Anastasia
welcome to the capital of Chess in
United States welcome back to San Luis
for Fisher random chess 9lx
hello everyone it's Anastasia Carlos GM
and I'm together with one and only yes
your serum and a one and only Anastasia
Anastasia wonderful for you to be back
thank you for joining our show thank you
so much it's a pleasure to be here with
you and Christian absolutely hello
everyone and thank you for joining us
and sharing your day with our show wow
uh day one was amazing uh in the 15
games that were played 12 were decisive
this Fisher random has something going
for it and Anastasia for those who kind
of Miss what Fisher random's all about
should we just give us brief explanation
exactly yes uh chess 960 is a variation
of chairs invented by Bobby Fisher in
June 1996. it was originally named the
Fisher random also known like chess 960.
um it's named like that because of the
960 about starting positions and there
were some restrictions in Bobby's
Fishers variant versus
random chess yes of course Bishops must
be placed on opposite color squares
makes sense so we cannot have two
Bishops same squared and also king must
be placed between the two Rooks why yes
sir yes so we can Castle left and we can
Castle right exactly and the players
will receive starting positions only 15
minutes before the beginning of the
round I
and we spoke about the decisive amount
of players the decisive amount of games
take us through the current standings
and we have a leader of the tournament
who scored 100 on the first day three
out of three great results and then
Fabiano caruana is on the second place
two and a half points not bad at all
indeed and the the wounded canned
alireza at two lots of players of fifty
percent Peter and Gary suffering not not
good and our format mxlacia and we have
a format Templars wrapped around Robin
thornland time control is 20 minutes for
the game was five seconds per move in
chess 960 the back rank pieces are
randomized a new starting position is
drawn before each round 15 years before
all boards have the same starting
position which is good and there will be
a playoff if there is a tie for the
first place and our schedule
it's three days event and we are already
on the day two round four begins at 2 pm
round five starts at 3 15 pm and don't
miss the round six which will start at 4
30 pm and everything will be decided on
Friday we'll have seven to nine rounds
tomorrow on Friday excellent as we see
the players arriving they're getting
wandered no electronic devices we're
joking with Gary that he would take out
like six devices
a digital watch and everything else
there we see alireza arugia who has just
won everything over 277 thousand dollars
in prizes since he's arrived in St Louis
and more to come but we're very lucky
very fortunate to have uh with us in
studio
Christian Christian what are you going
to tell us about today great to see you
guys what an amazing first day of chess
9lx chess we had yesterday it was just
incredible and one thing that stood out
was how many decisive games we had these
players are out for a blood in this
competition and they're definitely
enjoying themselves and of course in
particular round two stood out from the
rest with 5 out of five decisive games
and one game in particular was that game
between Hikaru Nakamura with the black
pieces defending for the whole game
against Gary Kasparov and after that all
the way towards the end Gary could have
won that game with a brilliancy
unfortunately for him he did not find it
and lost that match and look at him
right now maybe he's changing teams
we've seen him uh preparing with Peter's
video unfortunately for them it did not
work out so well for them both of them
are sitting on zero out of three right
now he's chatting with the leader of the
tournament and let's take a look at the
age of our participants as well and you
can see the discrepancy between Gary
kasprow 59 years of age and Ali Reza
firusha all the way at the bottom only
19 years of age just an incredible
discrepancy between these players and I
have to say Gary Kasparov and Peter's
wheeler it's not the age in my opinion
right now is just the fact that they
have not been as active as the other
players and that's why the result is
suffering for them and let's also take a
look at what happened in previous
editions of Chess 9lx we started off in
2019 it was actually a different format
we had a match format and you can see
some of the players that are also in
this year's event caruana versus
Kasparov that was a big match West we
saw versus Vaseline topalov's Villar
versus Dominguez and Nakamura versus
aronian and I remember aronian was
definitely leading very very dominant
start for aronian in that match he was
leading by five or six points at the
midpoint of the matching arm fortunately
for him Nakamura found some incredible
resources and managed to come back in
that match and actually win it in the
end 14 and a half to 11 and a half let's
take a look at what happened in 2020
well in 2020 we had due to the pandemic
a an online round robin and we actually
did not have any playoffs it was uh
Magnus Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura who
were the co-champions and in 2021 one
player that we have in this year's event
as well is Lanier Dominguez and he was
actually so dominant in the 2021 round
robin Edition it was an incredible event
that one but guys we have two more days
of very exciting chess 9lx yes we do
Christian and Anastasia do as the honors
and set the table for our viewers what
can they expect of the round four
pairings
round four bearings we have Wesley so
playing we're so struck we are Mommy
diaro nice Gary casparo please
the match of the generations clash of
the generations exactly and the leader
of the tournament she plays against
Fabiano caruana his closest rival
exactly and then linear Dominguez plays
against hikarnakamura and Peter swedler
against levonne and what are they
fighting for Anastasia they are fighting
for really good prices and the total
amount is 150k as you can see and the
first place will get 37 and 500 as well
as dance place even I mean the last
place will have really decent price
seven thousands and 500. yeah for three
days of hard work absolutely is again we
see the players in the playing Hall
getting ready for this round or getting
wanted making sure no electronic devices
that's what it's all about there is the
defending Champion yes
sitting at uh 50 on this tournament so
far one and a half out of three not
necessarily shaky of games actually
quite tame if I remember correct
now uh there's going to be a reveal of
the position the players are going to
have like 10 minutes or so to plot their
strategies uh from the first move and as
we saw in the day one
um The Players kind of attracted to one
another to work together just to figure
out their opening uh plans but it was
some of the players right we've seen
alireza film Indonesia and Hikaru
actually analyze on their own will and
they look for a partner perhaps today
well it's very interesting but what I
can see that Gary is in a very good mood
yes talk and it's really nice to see him
like that I've been considering also the
results at the first day exactly well we
had dinner with them last night with
Gary the three of us in fact
and Gary was actually in pretty good
move because he felt that he played well
he didn't have the results that's for
sure but he felt he played well now the
Arbiters have given the players uh the
position that they'll play in round four
they'll switch the position for Rounds
five and six and I think it's time for
us to also reveal to our audience what
the new position is shuffle them up
Anastasia oh that's kind of interesting
wow
this is position
927. okay
so break it down for us
um Christian what are the problem pieces
for the players and where would you see
the most likely
uh development plan well perhaps we can
see it on your board never mind I do
have the board updated so the way I see
it is the night on F1 is going to be
struggling to find a place
um on E3 I think that's going to be in
the way of the bishop also in the way of
The Rook on G3 this most likely will be
the natural opposition for the night but
nevertheless if you do put the Knight on
G3 you can very often expect ways in
which black is going to try to attack
that Knight maybe even via H5 H4 because
of the placement of The Rook on h8
already supporting that expansion so I
see the Knight as potentially being a
problem piece I really like this queen
on A1 and the bishopone C1 I see a
potential fianchiato development and
creation of a powerful uh battery on the
long diagonal something along the lines
of B3 if I remember correctly when I was
looking and when I was trying to analyze
this type of Chess 960 positions and I
do think that we had during the World
Championship in 2019 one of these type
of positions with the queen all the way
in the corner generally it was actually
B4 the move trying to take more space
not B3 not the shy B3 but rather a more
aggressive expansion move such as B4 and
them follow it up with Bishop 2 B2 so
once again the Knight on F1 f8
respectively are in my opinion the
problem pieces and you see already a
rook on E5 wow I know who's actually
assistant
Rook takes E5 is what Gary is analyzing
like and his
I think the pawn should go to B4
actually um
I I checked his recap yesterday and he
also mentioned that if Queen is in the
corner it's not a bad idea to think
about the moves like G4 or B4 even
though every time you have to take
um let's say take a look what's going on
in the center you still have to fight
for the center so you cannot really
devote only your time for developing
your queen right so it's important still
to keep an eye on on the center and once
again we see this theme they're so deep
already right this is like move six
seven eight they're doing right and you
see Peter and Gary they they're
shuffling pieces that move too but
Wesley and nepo are doing exactly the
setup that I wanted to do I was thinking
in terms of a Joko piano a quiet game
and I was thinking in terms of E4 E5
okay C3 so the idea behind C3 of course
is to make the classical Pond Center
let's just make a move for a moment
Knight C6
Bishop B3 aha you can already see the
Contours of a Joko piano but isn't the
queen going to suffer on A1 no I I got
this idea in mind I was going to go D 76
d2d3
Bishop E6 Knight D2 and what I was going
to say is kind of like what those
players you you have seen I'm going to
make a castles
I'm going to make Knight G3 and we get
karpov's favorite setup the two knights
and the queen will come out yeah
and then you're gonna help me thank you
Christian that's a very nice person
this is how we develop our Queen maybe
B3 B4 and uh Queen okay but this looks
too much like chess perfect yes perfect
very quickly this looks too much like
chess too much like chess I saw a Joko
piano coming out of this but I feel
there's an instinct with these players
to try to avoid chest positions for as
long as possible because they're
enjoying themselves they came to uh the
interviews and they were saying they're
enjoying this type of weird positions I
think they're going to try to avoid or
points
they're very much result oriented maybe
nepo and Wesley are taking that approach
but do you remember what level said
about E4 move that the first vet we play
E4 and we're trying to figure out if it
works or not
if we don't get hit with something uh by
the way I also like your approach that
you explain yesterday Anastasia you said
your your first thing is you look at the
pawn structure and you say where is the
weakness well
it's actually G2 and Jesus two uh pawns
that are only protected once the square
we're not attacking we're not attacking
D2 no D2 is covered three times so don't
concentrate there but that's why we've
been seeing also the players uh thinking
about the B7 B6 and Bishop B7 and you
were saying
um Christian that you like it uh before
before same idea of fear and shadowing
just grabbing more space take more space
and imagine this type of situation where
you go B4 and your opponent goes A5
right right then you have the option of
playing B5 right and that's not only
going to take more space but it's also
going to inhibit the night on B8 exactly
political Knight to C6 Knight to A6 you
have to find a different path for uh
that Knight this is another reason why I
like this idea with B4 and if you take a
look at or at least if you would have
taken a look a couple of minutes ago at
Fabiano and Lanier's position they were
actually analyzing this setup with the
pawn on B5 at some point Fabiano had a
phone on B6 and then he was like okay
what if I have the pawn on B5 will that
change right
here they've got a knight already so on
a very similar position to why they were
analyzing yeah so I think they're kind
of going in this direction D4 D5 Knight
C3
B6 and E4 and they're kind of going in
this direction of D5 takes E4 and now we
see in E7 E5
I noticed by the way on the leeches site
that I'm on that the leeches has a
database of people who have been playing
correct 960 over over the course of time
and I was joking with you yesterday when
I said aha a novelty and you said yes
there is something I was like what I
didn't even know there was a date of
such a thing there is a novelty in this
game apparently and actually just to
speak about that a little bit it does
seem more the engines are saying D4 is
the best move
um E4 has been played the most times
almost 3 000 games wow E4 yes E4 E5 is
the best according to the engine also
according to the database response uh B6
in is another idea as well Knight to G6
very interesting position I have to say
B4 has been played quite a few times as
well actually it seems like 350 seven
games have started with this move and
now it does seem like black is going to
try to play against this battery this
incoming battery so play the move D6
follow it up with E5 try to close this
Avenue for the queen and the bishop
nevertheless that most likely leads to a
very very aggressive setup for both
sides because you can start like this E5
Bishop to B2
D6 and then I have ideas of even F4 yes
at the right moment right
yes it can get the wired very fast the
motives I like look I can see Hikaru
starting with B4 if he's playing what is
he playing white no he's not playing
white he's actually playing Black so
he's going to be playing against
Domingos in today's first round now it
seems to be well as we were starting our
show there's this discussion but it
seems to me the Fisher randoms becoming
more and more popular than a US
Anastasia you were saying that Iceland
is going to be the host of the world
champion World Championship tell our
viewers a little bit about that what you
know I don't know that much but I know
that they all have really great price
ones and the most important thing
how much price I think 400 okay
something like that yes not bad I know
that Icelandic just Federation is
involved in charge of this event and
it's actually great news I mean I
remember the last event was was
organized in 2019 so it's great that we
finally have the world championship of
random chess video recognize this chairs
and to give the title of world
championship for those events only in
2018 I think the first time which is why
I supported Wesley because he's the
world champion of course absolutely but
it's already three years since the last
little Championship so we'll see we will
be playing that tournament I think yeah
there are some participants who are like
fixed participants and I think it's
Magnus yes Wesley uh one of the
Icelandic brand Masters yes exactly
and there is also
qualifiers yes yes so and it's still
unclear who will be playing the rest of
the field is still unknown they have
some matches some qualifying I believe
there was one player that already
qualified if I'm not mistaken safe but I
might be wrong about that yes so in any
case it's going to be really nice event
and I think Central's chess club also
contributed a lot with popularizing of
official Randomness absolutely these
chest 19 LX matches yeah and there we
see our isolani
alireza horusian but he's actually chit
chat this doesn't seem like any crap
duration and I'm wondering if Hikaru
remains isolated
and we got the magic shoes I mean all
right yes sir I I found out what they
are what are they extremely expensive oh
fashion shoes they're easies you know
Kanye West yes yes these are Kanye West
shoes
yes they look horrendous
[Laughter]
thinking they're kind of like a Swiss
cheese
slipper combination my goodness I can
imagine they called easies for a reason
that's very good I think we should put
my other one yeah that's right I want
you to wear some of this I will buy them
for you
I'm not sure I'll wear them
did you notice also that the father of
Philippines
I did I saw him probably it's possible
to stay for some time just on the
outside there and uh I want to give you
uh Christian a shout out because you
have been working with Fabi on doing a
video podcast and Fabi did a repeat of
pardon me a replay if you will of the
singfield cup and that was released
yesterday tell uh tell our viewers about
that and how they can subscribe yeah
yeah so we started uh discussing the
idea of a podcast sometime in May with
Fabiano actually during one of the
granchester events in Romania and uh he
seemed to be enjoying the idea and we
started off uh quite recently I think at
the end of August and you can find us on
YouTube Spotify Apple podcast yeah it's
called c squared c squared podcast
mostly on YouTube and on Twitter and all
social media and he did a review of his
performance in the single cup his
performance is a little satisfied I
watched the party podcast by the way I
enjoyed it a lot we are enjoying the
process of of doing it I think Fabiano
also welcomes
um other projects as well not just
playing chess right it's useful to have
a distraction right from just playing
just so I think he enjoys that aspect of
the podcast and also it's a lot of fun
to be talking we talked with you
actually today later on today uh the
podcast with you two hours with Yasser
Sarah one and and all the stories that
come along will be released about that I
was afraid that would be no no no no
destroyed the new Venture I was really
young I was like are you sure I mean
there we go there we go no it's actually
nice because Christian with no Christian
is a great commentator but also Fabiano
Karana I think when he years during the
world championship match we knew that he
is a great commentator but it was really
amazing to see him during the world
championship match when he made the
commentaries for chess come team at that
time and I think the positive feedback
that he got from that tournament
emboldened him as well a little bit to
take this Avenue yes he's really good
he's a natural
and here we have it our Marquee match up
there as uh nepo starting with 3-0 is
taking on his closest rival Fabiano with
two and a half and E2 E4 uh to open up
the game 45 looks like real normal
cheese exactly that's antsy okay here we
go towards our Joko piano he's trying to
build a pawn Center this classical
Central Pawn duo with the move d2d4 is
white as well as developing his Bishop
to B3 in order to attack the pawn on
F7 which as we discussed Anastasia is
the one of the weakest Pawns in the
position it's going to be hard to put
too much pressure on that pawn and here
we go you know what I think about like
maybe after G4 nepo and his style can
travel so F4 later you know D4 and F4
and just without a curiosity okay so
this move opens up uh the diagonal for
the queen which means an immediate D4
would involve Pawn sacrifice likely a
premature but I'm expecting something
like Knight G3 in order to defend the
pawn ah D3 right away I was about to say
Knight to G3 in order to defend upon
preparing D4 as well as Bishop D3 D2 to
E3 now this as far as I'm concerned is
an open invitation for black to try to
seize the center with the move D7 D5
whether it's good or not we have to
question but by the way I think D4 was
still possible because if ed4 CD4 then
rookie 4 or Bishop F3 well I'm not sure
but wow wow
F3 I have no idea what's happening after
because still click on C1 I think I have
a lot of compensation I think so too but
then just to notice that it's possible
that maybe it's nice to check it it's
unclear
Basics yes is coming soon okay here it
comes D7 D5 just uh uh
B6 D3 D4 is that D5 on the board yeah I
believe it's D5 yes I was afraid it was
my uh analysis board for a moment but D5
on the board yeah I was thinking okay
um Bishop Bishop B3 but Knight D2 Knight
G6 immediately trying to jump to F4 take
advantage of the fact that the bishop on
C1 doesn't control that square anymore
exactly I like the way Fabiano plays
actually he tries to fight for the for
initiative from the first moves yes it's
really impressive actually that's my bad
uh it was a and in fact this was what uh
nepo said as well yesterday during his
interview it's all about development
it's all about the initiative and he
showed case that uh strategy in his uh
incredible Victory 19 moves against
Hikaru Nakamura with the black pieces in
today's game it feels like he's taking a
very passive stance at least in the
first few moves
passive uh well that's d3c3 I'm not sure
I mean he's going for this uh very
common uh car pop setup with the Knights
on F3 and G3 most often from the Ruby
Lopez did uh karpov get these positions
he's gonna Castle he's gonna
it's funny because sometimes the bishop
can actually be good just on C1 you get
the bishop out of the way to develop The
Rook but I'm expecting this bishop will
come to B3
possibly to A4 if you can get a tease
you know this kind of tempo and the
queen will come to B1 so castles I
I
think
F7 F5 is something something
so I would probably play Knight G3
myself just to defend upon on e4 yet
again and uh control that five square
um what else is have any B4 takers yes
we have some B4 takers but this is
actually quite surprising guys because
Wesley so was analyzing with nepo and
nepo tried this passive approach E4 E5
C3 D3 Knight bd2 position just uh stay
like that Wesley on the other hand
started off with e for sure E5 and
immediately after Knight to G3 D6 Nitro
G3 is a very uh normal move he decided
to go with B4 so much more aggressive
and completely different strategy than
what we're seeing from his partner in
this tournament Nepal Nepal started with
C3 so B4 opens up the queen sets up this
potential battery on the long diagonal
with Bishop to B2 and also as we are
going to see in just a second castle
castle
A4 tries to expand on the queen side as
well A4 A5 probably is going to be met
with B5 exactly what we were predicting
and anticipating at the beginning of the
show Wesley seems to be thinking that
space is extremely extremely crucial in
this variants so that one is a very
interesting game also kasparo versus Ali
res actually that one is black as sharp
uh one that is definitely very sharp is
the one between Dominguez and Nakamura
and we were discussing about this
potential ideas at the beginning of the
show as well B3 and then set up
immediately uh the battery on the long
diagonal and the way to counteract that
is to go E5 and try to set up this let's
say uh King's Indian setup with E5 D6
and try to set up your pawns on the dark
squares Bishop to B2 D6 this is what we
have right now c4 Knight to g6d E4 and
right now Hikaru is thinking very
interesting position F5 is a possibility
but it looks dangerous right to move the
pawn in front of your king like that
fortunately for black there's no light
square piece coming on this diagonal
anytime soon because you already have
the pawn on B3 you committed your Pawn
to B3 so if you do want to get the
bishop to B3 you have to lose another
Tempo with the move B4 so F5 if you
gather all those details understand all
those details could become a natural
opportunity in this position thank you
Christian two games that really uh stand
out for me the First Once Again is the
gamer Gary Kasparov rather than in my
mind this is actually an incredibly
dangerous position for for Rouge
dangerous like how I mean it looks so
um tepid but in actuality it looked just
a little bit deeper I go Knight F3
I go B4
and I go Bishop to B3 this Knight on C6
is actually pretty woeful it doesn't
control the D5 Square this Pawn on C3
oops excuse me this Pawn on C3 is for
the moment controlling both of these
Knights once this Knight gets to F3 this
Knight is very unlikely to go to F4 I've
got fight Knight takes E5 and Bishop
takes F4 ideas so if I can play just one
two and three moves
um I'm going to be doing really really
well with the white side so I see this
as very dangerous and going back to the
game of our two leaders there was this
huge moment right here I thought okay
this is kind of boring nothing terribly
is happening and castles and the moment
castles came
said let's go H4 and uh and if you try
to go be uh behind the surface a little
bit you can see the strategy of leaving
the Knight on F1 as I was saying that he
did play the move Knight to G3 but first
initially he left the Knight on F1 and
then played this move H4 now what
possibilities does that take from black
well Bishop to G4 potentially is going
to be met by Knight jumping to E3 with
the Knight on E1 so I really like what
nepo is doing right now also he waited
for black to Castle right yes maybe he
wants to do a long castling
use that for the attack and do long
Castle later on maybe I thought about
the same two like maybe H6 now normally
speaking when you're playing moves like
H6 and you want to follow it up with H5
right but we're chasing the Knight to F4
and what's happening uh with these types
of tactics Knight takes is what if I
take no no I think maybe 95 95 93 yeah
yes 95
oh there's a fork that might be a
problem it is a fork sorry sorry
okay you can play Bishop D2 and save the
piece I lose an exchange but I'm not a
happy camper that wasn't my intention
I I needed my Bishop on B3 first by the
way a really cool move that Nepal just
did Bishop to A4 I really like that move
ah we were talking about Bishop B3 as
well as this tickle Bishop A4 the remind
black uh where the Rook is placed on EA
this Isis the bishop on C8 right now for
them right you have to go A6 B5 lose a
couple of tempies or maybe C6 but that's
going to close the queen I really like
this move Bishop to A4 very very crafty
move by Nepal yeah I I love it because
it really does uh we're gonna make a bad
move for uh black for because it really
does
is is pretty and we could even maybe
preface it with Bishop takes D7 so I
mean it seems like after this move
Bishop A4 uh Fabi has been outplayed
just a wee bit uh I like White's
position it feels like uh and for nepo
Holy Smokes 3-0 uh he's in a good mood
for sure he feels really happy with his
result right and we were laughing
yesterday because nepo oftentimes comes
in and he and the interviews and he just
beats himself I played idiot I I had
five buys uh I'm not playing good I
blunder I blunder I blood blunder and he
wants to get out of the interview boxes
as soon as he arrives yesterday yes he
was Mr eloquent we couldn't get rid of
it we had like is seven rapid games
going and he's like one other thing I'd
like to check that was pretty funny
Christian what what did you do you you
got them all excited yes I I guess he
was just excited because he won three
games in a row yeah and that might that
could do it that could do it I don't
think it was necessarily my presence
too much once I was trying to catch him
he ran away from me I was afraid he will
kill himself
because
to run away to his hotel no comments
please A7 A6 by Napo and uh Pardon Me by
Fabi and does this lay the groundwork
for the advanced H5 I mean
that's why I know
they chase me no so there's some very
interesting uh tactics in that line H5
94 if you do take on E5 yes I do have
Knight takes G2 and that might actually
be cool you know it's funny because that
was the kind of move I was expecting in
the previous uh uh thing a previous line
when I had overlooked the fork on D3
here you're still gonna have to end up
taking with the rub with a rookie yes
yeah and I don't know I mean I've got
this uh
Bishop F4 this kind of easier
development he did however nepo pardon
me did go for the development he wants
his Queen in the game oh pardon me A7 A6
and uh if the White Queen were on D1 on
Associated yes white would win
brilliantly by Bishop takes D7 followed
by Queen takes decision
which is why he played Bishop E3 in
order to bring his Queen into
civilization
who do you guys think it's better in
this position
I like but I like the question when such
kind of questions are are asked usually
there's usually a catch right yeah well
the things is Bishop to A4 and we were
saying that we really like the move that
white is doing great and black needs to
lose a lot of tempies to kick that
Bishop away from A4 and untangle his
pieces actually black is better
after A6 B5 lose those tempos no problem
you're still having a better position
and this just goes to show how difficult
it is to understand this weird chess 960
situations right and assess them because
this is key to uh the strength of these
players assessment they can assess the
positions on a dime so quickly and
that's what makes them great in this
just 960 with this crazy positions I
don't know if they can do that they lose
one of their superpowers
wow I was still kind of surprised that
black is doing as well as you suggested
we do have some moves after B5 Bishop B3
Knight F6 very logical move Queen C1
okay so this is a well I don't know or
think this is but there's a potential
sacrifice in the position Knight G4 both
defends the pawn on H6 while also
uh into meeting he will capture
H5 chases the night back Knight to E7
and is it time to play the move
and by the way the assessment changes
with every single right right so don't
trust the engines too much in this type
of situations for sure probably engines
also lose their strengths they're so
confused
rely on the engines in these type of
positions okay whoa whoa whoa Rook H4
that doesn't even threaten to take the
Knight Rook H4
I was wondering if I'm supposed to save
my Bishop with the move Bishop C5 but I
don't know what is that move on to stuff
I try to understand also that night can
jump now and Bishop from j8 will start
playing yes exactly but where was the
exactly like after 93 for example yes
and right if you take with say the queen
with a queen
then for example you cannot of course
Play Moves Like 95 because the Rook is
protected or 95 it's not good but maybe
just 926 let's imagine this move
before because the bishop is on right
yeah no I just don't like where this
Rook is going to have to go The Rook is
gonna have to come back
um and uh just to show you a very funny
variation and to pinpoint how weird the
tactics are and at this chess 960. if
you do go Bishop to C5 which you
initially wanted yes instead of Rook to
H4 yes now I go Queen to C6 how do you
follow that up with I want Bishop yeah
three right yeah exactly and now you're
almost lost after Queen to B6 Queen to
be which attacks the pawn on F2 oh yes
you're going to defend it somehow
probably you're going to Castle and now
I'm going to go C5 and now both of your
Bishops are starting to get attacked D4
is coming it's very difficult to get out
of that because A5 is going to support
the idea of B4 as well such weird
tactics
crazy we do have the strange move Rook
H4 we'll keep an eye on this how is the
clash of the generations uh going uh
Christian that one is quite a Time
Affair I have to say a very similar
structure as well what I'm worried for a
black forfeiture that is the queen is
still on it and there is no opening for
the queen yet so most likely B5 is an
option of course Bishop to E6 uh and
then getting the queen via C8 out like
that but you're still lagging in
development as black this is why I'm a
little bit worried nevertheless having
the structure solidified like that in
the center there's not a lot of
imbalances in the position so speed is
not as essential in this type of
structures this is what I'm saying it's
more or less a complex End Game 12
minutes for both players so Gary is not
falling behind on the clock either so
this is encouraging for him this one is
pretty crazy the one between Dominguez
and a Hikaru and take a look at what
happened in this one whoa after D4 he
played in the move E4 followed it up
with Knight to E5 blocking this diagonal
and stopping the attack on the pawn on
G7 Knight to G3 F5 Castle H5 he's
burning a lot of bridges on the king
side potentially will go on the queen
side with his King but you have to
vacate so many pieces and so many
squares before you can do that you're
going to get checkmated before you can
do that and F4 Knight to G4 E3 H4 Knight
to H1 Knight to F6 this is the current
position that we have right now on the
board what I'm seeing is a big
discrepancy in development no piece is
developed on this side for black still I
have the Knight to get out this night to
come back to F2 but everything else is
more or less developed so I definitely
prefer white in this one did I spot a
pussycat there was there a pawn hanging
on G7
uh at what point well right when I
booted the night so instead of e3 right
yeah instead of it yeah G7 yes that was
that was a move
um what I assume was his worry is that
after Rook to H7 you have to come back
probably you have to come back to D4 so
that Knight E3 is not coming in the
position for example if you go Bishop to
C3 or Bishop to B2 Knight to E3 and you
actually might have some problems okay
uh the position so you have to go Bishop
to D4 and then I can follow it up with
C5 so it does seem like black gets some
speed not only that but after you take
on C6 and I take back the bishop is
under attack also my Bishop on d8 is
becoming active this is a huge threat
right now Knight takes D4 so for example
I take take whoops your queen is lost
right suddenly your queen is lost
because of the fact that your Pawn is
already on F2 and this diagonal opens up
so probably looking at these variations
understanding the fact that he's playing
Hikaru Nakamura who is such a dynamic
player he said no no I'm not taking that
point
nobody believes you as Ben Larson would
say put that but there wasn't that C5
back on the board hey you're saying that
because they're not your pieces yes I
want to take on C6 okay I want to take
on C6 and I want to play E3 sure yes and
I want to take your knight on T4 the
engines are saying that white is better
in the position thank you from a
practical perspective it's all about the
Practical perspective and he just didn't
feel comfortable no it's not it's all
about the pawn thank you Anastasia
welcome to the show welcome to the show
when you're going to get more
invitations like membership
Christians on Shaky Ground right
what about the nepo game Let's jump back
to our two tournament leaders
whoa uh Chaos on the board we've got an
exchange sacrifice yes what to do you
cannot really admit that you have to
move the stroke right exactly so you
this you normally give it but it's a new
trend actually in chess so especially
nine uh
um Alex you give up your exchanges here
there almost every round we have an
exchange sacrifice great yes we have in
America a grand master Alexander Ivanov
once he is a knight on G5 and his
opponent has played H6 and
Alexander captured the pawn on F7 the
big blunder why did he do it he was
asked a Russian never Retreats
because the explanation Rook went to H4
with purpose he won back his exchange
look at this bishop takes now I'm
feeling I don't understand
I don't want to see a bishop takes G7 a
knight F5 check and a F3 land I don't
want to have anything to do so you know
you you do want you know to sacrifice
the bishop Bishop takes E4 but I think
whoa whoa whoa there's Bishop takes G2
oh a Christian my spidey sense is
tingling but
this is something for who yeah exactly
it's opportunity but for who exactly and
there's another move Hidden Gem in the
position that is Queen to A7 yes again
the same idea it's all about keeping
that Bishop from returning home the
bishop on a fate right each point of
Fate uh the best Avenue to return home
and actually take a passive and
defensive approach is to get it back via
C5 if you do go all the way to A3 then
we've seen in the variation that I
previously showed that bishopone A3
might become the mark of an attack via
a5b4 so it's not a great position for
the bishop I really like this move Queen
to A7 let's wait and see whether Fabiano
will find this one but once again guys
look at the difference on their clocks
Fabiano 6 minutes and 20 seconds his
opponent nepo is playing so fast making
decisions so quickly 14 minutes and 27
seconds besides the move Queen A7 what
happens in this whole series of captures
because there are captures Galore right
we could capture this guy we can capture
this guy we can even go and just capture
A2 so where do you want to capture first
I don't know
before first let's take that out okay
let's start with the obvious you cannot
do that because I take with the Rook and
that's a that's game well there's a
knight on G4 still hanging that's a game
over okay take on A2 so you can take
away two I believe King takes a f8 was
played Kinte is a faith on the board on
D5 this is what we currently have now
Queen to d8 that's a good move that's a
nice spot by Fabio look at this
is very nice yeah it's all about these
weird tactics I mean is he just maybe
going to be a pawn up in this position
well I don't think you can take on C6
right I can toss a knight G6 check ooh
okay just let me take just to make the
confusion complete
and now I guess Queen to H4 is actually
not going to help me that much right
because I only have a track it's it's
rather empty I I I it's just a check but
it might be really good you never know I
mean if you could get in king a king G8
and Rook f8 it could be I also feel that
if I allow you to take on G6 that pawn
is going to be so powerful so I take you
take on C6 and maybe I take on H5 just
simple checks Simple Choice yes because
right now actually it does feel like a
transposition right but then
maybe I don't know there's there there's
definitely avenues for for your PCS to
get in
um it's a complicated battle sure it's
it's a really common I like this
Logistics yes it's nice I like the queen
d8 I like the double hit but I think I
like Queen A7 best uh when he had that
opportunity uh there was a moment there
in the Gary because whoa the Gary
Kasparov game has blowed up another
exchange sacrifice on on board here and
did Gary make a good decision let's take
a look we left it around these parts and
let's see where it all went
well Bishop B3
my first impression is this is very good
for Gary right my very first impression
is very good because I've got these
ideas of Knight takes C7 as well as
night here but it's difficult to move
the Knight right now right pardon me
sorry it's difficult to move the Knight
because that would allow the exchange of
the last pair of Rooks for white and I
think that's going to improve my chances
as black to defend and ask you where's
the compensation you're still an
exchange down for a pawn for a pawn yes
I mean very important is pawns
um okay let's just take a quick look if
I go Knight takes wait what
wow
it was actually called Dangerous
that's not the nice way of putting it uh
wait wait wait guys guys guys but uh you
go 1967 I go to f8 right you can get
shade call move and Knight is defending
the Rook you go King f8 shall we explain
to Christian white king no no no no no
no like a root cafe
after Knight takes G7 I don't take one
ah you you change your mind but I think
yes as a refutation Rook f8 is probably
very good
um so let's take on F2 let's see how
that plays out okay and now I go B6 or
B5 sure
but after Queen G5 I think I have ideas
of Rook to G8 simply yeah
very cool okay very sharp position right
suddenly suddenly sharp and what are the
times oh the times I think how is Gary
doing six minutes 35 seconds and
thinking right now he needs to prove his
compensation but Gary did you see that
yeah like with the hands just kind of
like where did my time
could I also ask another saline question
I'm a pond Grabber Knight takes C7 I'm
forking the queen and Rook you have to
take your queen is hanging I don't know
where you want to put it you f a you you
tell me later and then I
I've got two Pawns a little bit of a
damage King
no I can't say that I'm better it's
compensation good compensation but I
can't say that I I'm I'm pleased enough
to to call it an advantage Gary's
looking for more but it is it there is
it there Christian or not uh according
to the engines and once again it's it's
all about the practicality in this type
of situations it's not about the
objective evaluation with only six
minutes on the clock in such an
imbalanced position according to the
engines Rook to E3 and Rook to E4 keep
the balance in the position but it's so
difficult to make a passive
right you're just getting out of the
check correct because I don't think Rook
to G3 is coming anytime soon because
Rook tc6 would come on the board so I
can just simply defend that pawn and
then you have to go Knight to G5 trade
on E3 and then play that position as it
is it's not that easy from a human's
perspective to make this type of
decisions this is why I'm worried I
think he's looking for something
immediate as you guys were and this is
exactly what we see Knight takes E7 on
on the board Knight takes C7 after
I want to say a long thing Anastasia
that was uh how many minutes four
minutes four minutes that's a lot of
time in these 20 minute games let's jump
back to nepo and Fabi sorry to just
focus on these two games but they're
bringing the action no Knight G6 check
business by the way we left it around
these parts we were expecting a knight
G6 to get tossed in it did not happen
Queen takes H4 queen and the queen
landed on F5
and the pond structure
a little bit
funny these double Pawns
this nice we could have something like
Queen F4 now it looks like a really
normal chest yes we do have
a queen F4 and very quickly rook and
seizing the open file and saying look
there's this doubled Pawn there's this
double Pond but I have an active if you
trade Queens this is what I want is
white that I can drop a rook on to D7
still
um looks fairly balanced what do the
engines have to tell us about this
position the engines are saying that
blackish is up winning winning black is
winning didn't didn't know it's a D1
Queen to C4
um and just pick up the pawn on C6 which
is depending on whether you defend it
with Queen to F3 or and you allow me to
take on A2 or you try to defend A2 when
you alone your lips to uh
he it's on the board and it just seems
like you don't have enough compensation
to actually create any sort of motion
with your pieces around my king So if
you cannot do that then my position as
black I'm going to pick up one pawn and
I'm going to return with the queen to E6
close to home and I'm just going to be a
pawn up
this is a chest position right now so
upon up in chest position well that's an
interesting yeah for some reason I had
been focused on Queen F5 but Queen C4 so
much better it's so obvious too I mean
you're just the spawn on C6 uh it could
be a dangerous and it feels like the
body language also changed right now a
little bit after Fabiano relax a little
bit take a sip of his water understand
the fact that right now he's just Batman
yeah and apple doesn't like it no Napa
doesn't does not like it he he kind of
move this Rook back to E1 or the kind of
a Grimace there as if to say well that
didn't work out very well you mentioned
A2 I can take that why not that's a good
one because the problem with Queen takes
A2 is Rook takes E5 I might get landed
on the back rank right this Knight G4
ideas so I have to play Knight F1 but
then if you play Knight F1 then that
Knight is very passive right and there's
E5 E4 saying look I I don't want to
trade off the pawn on E5 for the pawn on
C6
yes I just want to eat I like it as
Anastasia this is looking very good for
a Fabby let's just check in on on Wesley
and Shaq for a moment haven't seen this
is more what I was trying to get this uh
I want to say Joko piano like positions
interesting that we have H5 H4 but we
see the natural active player uh
Christian that's taking over actually
see Carl hecaro is a very good position
right now against our defending Champion
yes he does that Rook on D4 is tied to
the defense of the D5 opponent it's
going to be so difficult to liberate
that rook in the meantime I'm just going
to double up on the C file take control
of the C file the only open Square in
the position and then just simply be
much better
is black permitted to Castle has he
moved uh no no no not can still Castle I
don't know if you want to Castle though
right maybe you just want to go King F7
are you sure the Rook The Rook would
maybe land perhaps off the route to ca
but in the future maybe I can go King F7
so either King F7 or Rook f8 I think he
wants to he's reaching for the Rook to
come to fa he just wants to connect his
Rooks so as you say Christian he can
challenge the C file but by the way what
do you touch first
discussion or The Rook right now yes I
think you should touch your king first
because castles is considered a move
with the king so you just tap it yeah
it's crown and then take the rook and
move it I remember in in Oslo there was
some issue with
um no there was one so actually
situation Nepal yes played I think was
Hikaru yes that's the rook and then made
a castle yes yes and and he was a
discussion right right right okay so
we'll keep an eye on this one again Gary
Kasparov faruga exchange for two pawns
that's actually a good question how to
do Castle you know not we'll know
already how to move the knights but how
to do the castle we're still we're still
in the process of learning
yes uh Knight takes F6 that was a
surprise for me uh right here I was
expecting Queen D4
when you trade you usually want to trade
on your terms so in this case the bishop
looks pretty good you can anchor the
bishop but he Gary just took on the F6
right away and Rook takes F6 on board
again and Bishop and two pons usually
it's sufficient compensation not too
exciting let's go to Peter Fiddler and
you think you think he's going to be
able to survive this
um
we'll see clocks will be a factor uh
just jumping to a game we haven't looked
at uh Anastasia Peter swidler Who coming
into today's action really needs to get
on the scoreboard as does Gary
um Bishop on D4 pardon me the bishop on
D6 looks good but
this Pawn
should go to B5 I don't know how to get
it there but
threads like room G6 are here now from
black side D6
do we need to defend or not well how
much are you what kind of uh piece
amount you're gonna end up with two row
no yes
at the moment so night makes sense as uh
the queen is a terrible blockader the
Knight is a great blockader so on a good
day black would love to move his Queen
drop his Knight on C6 and then say aha I
release my queen
um Christian your take on the position
between Peter and Lavon lavon's actually
having a nice tournament for the ages
aged players absolutely no I I like what
LeBron is doing right now I mean I don't
see a way in which you can make use of
that pawn on C5 so if it's not the
strength in the position then it could
easily turn into a liability right
because I'm going to go Knight to F5 or
perhaps the idea that you were
mentioning I do I am tempted to just
like try to kick that Bishop away one of
its main Defenders and then focus on
picking up the pawn on C5 oh that was an
interesting effect that we just had by
the way I just saw the move rookie one
it was kind of played with a little slap
on the clock which means that the time
is beginning to irritate Peter a bit
four to four they're actually head to
head right now on the clock four minutes
and 16 seconds for Peter four minutes
and 10 seconds for Levon but I do like
this idea of Knight F5 how do you
ultimately defend that pawn on C5
good well what you said the bishop could
turn into a liability opponent C5 also
uh turning back to our Marquee matchup
of our two tournament leaders when we
left it uh nepo took back his move he
went Rook D1 and then Rook back to E1 we
saw the movie yes maybe that I think
this is the hardest thing in chess is to
recognize you've made an error he
followed it up with F2 F3
yes
G2 G3 and we have
very peculiar position on the board
rookie six it feels like if we just make
a trade
of the C6 bond for the E3 Bond that's
just going to be a draw the king
will happily come closer to the E3 pawn
and pick it up and unfortunately for all
the Gary fans I think the position is
simply going down right now oh
he's losing upon no by force
he allowed the wow again I thought this
bishop should be on the D5 Square you
know doing a dual Duty you know covering
the king covering the queen side uh oh
here we see the strength of a rook over
the bishop
it weakens all the other pawns as well
on the queen side exactly maybe he was
hoping to play Bishop of seven Gary is
not looking happy he's holding his head
in his hand like what
what am I doing also oh okay Faith first
okay so he's focused on the F to pawn
okay uh no choice here King G2 is a kind
of a force bot a forced move and I guess
now it's time to pick up that pawn on B2
yeah it's gonna be said
because yeah and there goes the pawn the
moment the bishop goes uh Christian
mentioned that's a resignation
that it weakens all the queen side and
he wow he just uh to defend that landed
the position away he's not interested in
defending that yeah so it's I mean it's
a parable of a guy who got really good
position out of the opening and played
really interesting game until certain
points so yeah it's a Pity again exactly
uh turning our attention to Lanier
versus Hikaru I think that uh Lanier has
done a good job at least of bringing his
Knight back to C3 but the moment you
start really digging into the position a
bit you start to realize more and more
that this Pawn is basically a liability
and it's going to be incredibly hard to
maintain the pawn B5 B4
kicking away the night
and allowing for Knight takes D5 and
here it comes and alcaro's in Pole
Position the time situation is looking
very dire for uh White right now for
linear if you do try to go Rook to B4 I
think after Rook to C8 you might be in
deep deep trouble
or go to the D4 so he decides to play it
like that
okay the good news for Lanier's fans is
that B4 actually does allow Knight A2
and not so easy so perhaps let's try to
go Rook to C8 can we can we look at that
position sure the ca what do you do now
do you take my Pawn first of all let's
check if you take the bone I mean I'm
afraid so if you take the pawn I'm going
to start with Rook C1 arroxy one Rook C1
yes okay Rook to C1 check I just want to
to win this one by force if I have a
passion of this yes
um Rook to C2 or Bishop takes B5 yes
even Bishop takes P5 is very tempting
absolutely followed by Knight to G4
followed by root to C2 yeah or to C3
perhaps
actually yes king2 Rook to C3 it's
starting to look very very dangerous
very shaky
that's really good it was dangerous a
long time ago now this is kind of
looking lost actually nice uh nice
analysis there and he played C8 actually
and Rook C8 he's
1955 and now now's the moment of truth I
love The Rook C1 check but it wouldn't
surprise me if Rook C2 isn't a similar
kind of a winner I like that move that
you made as well yes wrote the C2
because then I can kind of follow what
you just did a moment ago takes takes
and Knight to G4 E3 is hanging but so is
the back rank but yes sir let's try to
actually calculate it all the way until
the end because I have a feeling you can
win some okay he's going for the line I
propose and I think Rook G1 is going to
come yes or G1 well H4 Pawn
that's going to be a lady suit it sure
is oh dear oh dear let me just refresh
my board first second as hikaru's move
is even stronger it looks decisive it
really really does
and by the way should he win this
Anastasia it's going to be the second
Victory first I mean he did not have a
good day one not by his standards and
his standards are incredibly high of
course even though he was really happy
to defeat Gary Kasparov absolutely Eric
to A4 and then here is looking for some
counter chances
but is it too little too late that is
for sure I was thinking that he's going
to kind of Go Jack and maybe making some
squirrels with quarrels with his Bishop
so do you think on H2 right now or do
you take on E3
I love that past age Pawn Knight takes
H2 Knight F3 H3 and yeah right because I
don't like I mean that's
the only thing he needs to make sure is
that he's not going to fall under some
sort of Perpetual check somehow which I
don't see it coming anytime soon
well first of all yeah King F6 is kind
of safe but even if I crawl along the
back rank towards the king king to d8
although
in that case I'm giving up the D6 Pawn
okay well Lanier but I think I'm just so
much faster so let's go Knight takes H2
right now he takes H yes okay so then
okay seven and let's go King d8 I think
I can play actually any King Moon king
of six Bishop B8 do you have to check
yes Bishop E8 and then you have one
check I don't see the follow-up even
after even in that situation I don't see
them like even so you go Bishop to E8
now I go let's say Knight to F3
than H3 so the moment you you have a
discover check it's not working
everything is protected exactly and if
you go Rook f8 for example I'm not going
to allow you to get behind my Pawn no
that's that yeah
this is where you're supposed to say and
black can never lose
don't remind me of that that was the
commentator's curse on steroids that was
amazing you you called it perfectly
King f8 on the board he's just I mean
this H Pawn is and five seconds two
seconds he has to make a move one second
with one second seven oops one second
seven seconds right now but the two is
the G6 no the G8 no more checks well you
can go roku8 but King H7 is going to
come on make it move three seconds two
seconds
he's trying to put the bishop on G6 do
not allow him to do that so yeah King H7
is an automatic and uh that's exactly
what Hikaru did but now it's too little
too late uh you win the pawn on D6 he
wants to play Bishop G6 but here you can
also got Rook B2 and then Knight F6 I
start with Knight F6 actually I love
that move just making sure all the
counter play against my king is stopped
yes Knight F6 that's how he chooses wow
that's such a powerful move there's no
stopping the H Pawn guys as soon as that
Rook moves as you say Christian the B2
it's absolutely
H3 first or Rook to B2 whenever you go
Bishop to E6 to attack my F5 Pawn I go
King G6 and
Lanier is prepping Rook moves King G1
but that's not yes two that is not going
to help because Knight to G4 is going to
defend upon a nation
is coming yeah by the way Hikaru played
this wonderfully well shacriar has
defeated Wesley oh my goodness wait what
I've got a I got a zero one on my score
I've got a zero one yes yes yes yes I I
think he did defeat Wesley not with the
last move that's on the board right now
Knight to D5 but he did defeat Wesley
they're analyzing so the dgt boards are
picking up the moves we think that
Wesley lost on time he just forgot to
did flag yes oh my goodness now the
position was hopeless stunning Peter
Fiddler versus Lavon by the way Peter's
Fiddler looks like he's actually
boys lavon's King and some check mating
box
I mean it's close it's a very very close
and uh Rook check yeah you see he has
Knight on F3 right
Knight F3 King back to G6 trying to
fight to H7
Knight okay I don't have the exact we'll
keep our bird's eye view here but
somehow I think there's a white King on
E6 yes there is I don't know how we got
there
I'm just going to put it there and okay
and because F5 and G4 was a threat of
mate and he didn't want to allow the
king to go to F7 so now what rookette
shade not really yes
perhaps he's trying to go together so we
go
[Music]
you have to defend against that you have
to check that with Bishop before right
now number six is not possible because
no Rook B6 and Knight f8 so if he could
play F5 Bishop before it has to be
played yeah that's right but now I have
five there's no more checks for you and
F6 F6 is going to be a mating pattern
this is dangerous guys
it's really dangerous trying to give his
King some room
he's not F6 is going to be a mate right
right
I'm thinking I might even try to tighten
the net a little bit with H4 yeah I
thought about this crazy Rich foreign
I'm not a big fan of allowing the king
to go to G5 though of course of course
that is a that is a problem
by the way G5 looks like a crazy threat
to go King F7 check
I like this move
follow it up with King but he's allowed
the king to escape if he had I have F6
was a win it was a win earlier not
anymore he took the pound
drum game maybe wow Lavon got lucky he
escaped
surprisingly there was nothing there was
no win there was no wind no
okay there was no like maybe net
Checkmate net
I think we have to come back at one
point to see afterwards so let's go to
Fabiano guys because white is winning I
think Nepal completely turned it around
what he won
whoa oh we missed it all right and he's
laughing he's like okay I got away with
one in this oh no I sure did oh it's
possible how is that possible well we we
left it when the pawn on E3 was going to
be captured captured for the pawn on
C6 like somewhere back here we just the
king just happened
yes uh you couldn't take on the uh on
c694 with the thread exactly King takes
C6 as you say Anastasia that would be a
a fork
uh what is oh Fabby had some clever idea
of winning the bee Bond
but you know what that pawn on C6 lives
that is not a good thing
oh
oh my goodness
and I can't believe it but we have nepo
at four out of five he's dominating I
think he's like also he's running away
with it yeah
yeah that position so this should be uh
this should be drawn no yes it was drawn
all the way until the end close to the
end
not this one once you once you take the
piece that's too much really the pawns
are too separated so after A4
pardon me right don't go for the night
the night is already tied to the defense
of the Pawn on G5 then I cannot move
correct what you have to make sure of is
that once the Knight moves from H3 you
are ready to take on G5 and then
sacrifice as fast as possible the Knight
on the last Pawn the pawn on A4 the way
to do that is with the move Knight to D3
yeah exactly King A5 and now Knight B2
keep contact with the pawn on A4 at all
times nice but probably didn't have much
time at this point wow that's the
problem 15 seconds for Fabiano at this
point he should have found it though
because it's material is quite limited
so
it doesn't feel that difficult right
yeah but Anastasia once again we have an
80 percent
decisive result we've got four out of
the five games here around four and uh
wow
and by the way uh through the magic of
TV what we're gonna do is take a look at
Wesley so he's thinking he's thinking
he's thinking he's thinking for 40
seconds
13 10. he's already thought for 30
seconds here we go here we go here we go
here we go
and he completely forgot about his clock
yes and he just resigned yeah cannot
believe it only once in my life he
didn't flag but he was completely lost
at that that because that 93 wasn't sure
it was a shock
um wow but still I mean you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah you make you make a move
just because you're down on the clock
yes
um
Gary Kasparov uh I think you hit the
nail on the head when you said Gary it's
not the issue of age is the issue that
he's just rusty as all get out he hasn't
played in a year I think so I I think
this is exactly what it is he plays only
a couple of tournaments uh per year and
whenever he does he plays against the
best chance players on the planet and
also the most active players on the
planet so there's a big discrepancy
there and I think this is the biggest
problem that he's encountering right now
just you know as a player you know
there's so many decisions while you play
a game of chess of Chess nine elex so
whatever variant you're playing there's
going to be a lot of very difficult
decisions that you will have to make
throughout the game and they usually
take time the more active you are the
more in shape you are the faster you
take those decisions so this is exactly
what we're seeing right now from Gary
He's unable unfortunately for him to
make those decisions in time he falls
behind on the clock and then and panic
intervenes and unfortunately makes the
bad decisions
yes indeed and here Anastasia current
standings after four rounds another
surprise the only bonus she has four out
of four 100 again and he's on the first
place and our Golden Boy is back to his
winning ways exactly and he just beat
Fabiano
is on the second place with three points
replacing Fabian on the second place and
Fabian is on the third position right
now together with Lebanon and Shakira
mediaro then we have Hikaru Nakamura who
just won his game and now yes yes he has
50 and then we have Wesley saw and the
others absolutely as we get ready for
our break tell us what Q Boutique is uh
what's the specials today yeah cubic is
really really important we have today
our sport camo flash black ball cap and
it's available in different sizes it's
100 percent polyester and includes the
gs9lx logo on the front and St Louis
chess club logo on the back what a nice
what nice up can I try it yes sure for
us yes okay let's check it oh very very
very becoming yes I can see it's going
to be a hot seller maybe I should stay
like that exactly
round five coming your way we'll see you
on the other side of the break
[Music]
we all know St Louis is a championship
Sports Town from the 11 time world
champion Cardinals to the Stanley Cup
champion Blues but I bet you didn't know
about all the championship places there
are to get out and play here like the
World Chess Hall of Fame Westport social
and Topgolf and now even our own MLS
team so whatever Sports your team is
into you can always bring out your A
game in St Louis
oops sorry St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
hey family Welcome to our show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we have our standings right now
welcome back everyone to our show and we
have Yandy publisher leading the
tournament after four rounds four out of
four perfect score my goodness
unbelievable
has three points and then Fabiano
Carolina
all of them have two and a half points
Hikaru Nakamura at 50 and other players
are unhappy as we get ready for this our
fifth round coming up now you're going
to have to do the honors and tell us who
uh are going to do battle
yeah so we have also the pairings of
round five and we have Lebon aronian
playing against Wesley so the Chicago
plays against Peter sweetler Fabiano
caruana linear Domingos
faces there it is once more our Marquee
match up as we see the number two player
and the number one player go
head-to-head and dream come true again
for Shakira who will play against Gary
Kasparov
right
and let's take a look at our new
position shuffle them up Anastasia tell
us what you're going to deliver oh yes
let's see what's going on it's a
position 196.
and
we can see at least Queen is not in the
corner anymore
and what about the pawns G2 h2r
unprotected wow this is what I noticed
immediately it's the same for G7 and H7
is we have the same position for white
and white exactly exactly so any attacks
on those two pawns G2 H2 uh they are
possible actually Bishop is on B8 right
right so some opening move c2c4 as well
sc5 yes are possible yes so if you play
C4 immediately at seven pound uh is
attacked you know when we think about
the chess 960 positions and I think that
was what Lavon also mentioned uh
yesterday I don't like those positions
where the Bishops or all four Bishops
are in the corner because it means
everybody's going to play you know B2 G2
and the bishops get get traded but the
two knights in the corner as a Christian
what do you think of them
well um my look at the position and I
think that this is actually going to be
the closest one we have to potentially
leading to a very natural game of chess
I don't see any bad pieces in the
position Knight to F3 jumps there Knight
goes to G3 the other might goes to G3
you go C4 D4 something along those lines
you get this bishop out to C3 you get to
Castle the king very very quickly on the
short side and after that I mean this
bishop goes back to D3 or C2 it just
feels like a very natural position and I
don't see what the bad piece in this
setup is so I'm definitely uh feeling
that we're going to see a lot of very uh
chess looking games in the next round
it's nice to see players actually
analyzing though you can see all of them
are enjoying this moment right and you
can see Knight on F3 Knight on G3 and
the Bishops are coming out slowly but
sure exactly uh
for uh perhaps this is what you should
would be focused on actually getting
that pawn to C4 because you want to have
the pushpoints between behind the pawn
if you don't if you keep the pawn on C2
then the bishop on B1 is going to suffer
so I think the move C4 probably has to
be played quickly actually it's very
funny we had three players analyzing now
we have four of them soon maybe the
whole tournament as well we'll just
stand next to one position and so
there's four players and a Leonard I
don't have the position on my computer
they're Christian so uh take it again
what you and you you say this this
opening or this position
they're analyzing right now if we have
normal Shepherd's eye view of the
position so yes they are starting with
the move C4 which makes a lot of C4 C5
C4 C5 Knight to G3 G6
okay why G6
oh they want to play Bishop but Knight
to F3 yeah
I have seven look at this
you cannot play just like that it's too
crazy
right I mean they give it a try
and they saw that question is having a
lot of fun with his ideas
I really don't believe in this G6 E4
Bishop E5
so Jan seems to want to go Knight H6 F5
a different approach
very very interesting
what's happening but uh yeah I see also
E4 they check the moves like E4 I'd have
three nights but I'm seeing also the
bishop no that is a problem G2 sorry
uh that there you had the issue of the
weak Pawn on G7 oh because uh sacrifice
right now nobody is really defending
this Pawn
interesting idea five sometimes yes
right very very quickly hitting this
Pawn so what he was started
and now looked you
maybe we can also check what Gary is
checking right now like what is he
analyzing at this moment with Peter's
wheeler perhaps
all right so he doesn't have this angle
Peter move your hand you are a
commentator I will end upon on H2 so you
got snapped but I tell you you lose so
much time to take just a H Pawn it's one
thing when you're winning a center Pawn
but why was he so happy with it because
then he could just move the queen right
so let's see the first move which which
move they would like to make after all
conversations
E4 or D4 okay they're checking D4 maybe
they're actually checking like E4 G4 all
the moves normal moves let's say at the
beginning it is kind of C5 is really too
provocative I would I mean I'm a pond
Grabber and I I don't like losing the
time
uh so much time is being lost there
yeah and yes look white got such a great
sentence
that Bishop is going to get kicked at
six
oh interesting so just to keep control
over E5 Square
ah there is another reason why this
[ __ ] Point F4 is useful because you
cannot Castle alongside and if you go G3
try it Bishop H6 yeah and the Knight on
H1 is completely it's kind of uh killed
this is this is a creativity right based
on of course some positional
understanding let's put it this way
C4 Knight G6
uh the same oops you know they're
trading pawns okay
just three years I thought about it okay
you give up your night but you get two
Bishops for example well now you have
taken and now you have to take oh it's
not suggesting
what about Knight F6 what's the problem
that's a queen right oh it's Queen it's
a queen yes it would defend H7 yeah
interesting awesome
10 different things okay that's a nice
one
but it amazes me how quickly they've
come to their conclusions and Fabian
Lavon they don't even move pieces they
just talk to one another
training
wow okay now c4 all right
[Applause]
I say what oh yeah
nobody understands what's going on okay
if you said hey you should say B let's
go g three or one yeah
open up the bishop to build a C3
chronological place
beautiful takes no
I'm confused yeah me too yes it's too
deep too deep yes in this kind of
opening choice
it's very deep I remember one Grand
Master Robert
was asked to describe uh praying Mr Ella
marovich and he said too much talent
by the way I think this is the first
time I'm seeing the engine at move one
before move one actually give white
quite a significant Advantage usually
0.20.3 Max in this starting position is
actually 0.5
0.5 0.5 with the move Knight to G3
Knight to G3 Knight to G3 immediately
potentially um
interesting yeah there there are certain
starting positions where especially when
there's a queen on H1 attacking
upon on B7 for example and this move G3
and somehow it's very awkward to defend
the pawn on B7 and the move Knight and
here we were we've been seeing the
players playing for C2 C4 and attacking
H7 and the move Knight G3 I don't quite
have the starting position on my board
yet we do have it on uh Christian but
we can't elaborate further on the point
value of the starting position in normal
chest yes we're at 0.02 leader actually
wants to play the movement the computer
is starting to look at the position and
it's saying 0.2 as well Knight to G6 and
then if you do go for the pawn with
Knight to H5 protect it in fact just
sacrificing the park sacrificing the
pawn not only that but they're actually
running away with the bishop so you're
not allowing a white to exchange the
Knight for the bishop you're going to
run away somewhere C6 A4 A4 is an
interesting uh to want to bought I'm not
100 sure why he likes this move so much
I would say Bishop to B5 or Bishop to C6
are the much more natural approaches and
then you have to lose some time to get
your night out because otherwise the
Knight is going to be trapped on a G7
Queen to G4 is a very nice move as well
by the way my guess will be that players
will not go for this kind of
continuation because it's really risky
right I mean you can lose your knight
maybe the computer knows everything but
it's very hard none of them are actually
looking at to start with this move
Knight to G3 they want to gain as much
space from the beginning so they're not
even thinking about this uh Knights or
teams early on
hmm
interesting it's just seeing this match
up once again between our two top uh
tournament leaders leaders right four
for four is nepo with the black pieces I
mean normally speaking we would be
saying Ali razor fantastic what a score
three out of four you're doing great
kiddo but after winning all the events
he might be even sad a little bit right
now tell us uh what do you think about
the psychology of the two players again
they just played a playoff for uh
Anastasia for the title you're right
right and nepo was Sour or should I say
salty yeah
[Music]
and also after move E5 yeah
it was really early residence day he
just literally won that final and became
the winner of single cup and everything
else the grandchester and yeah so here
we go C4
huh
yeah
and C5
well so far in both alibraza and
Fabiano's games uh C4 was the first move
and Nakamura started with Knight G3 very
interesting ah so now is the only one
wow as of now that starts with a peace
move Majesty it's still on perhaps he
analyzed this position you know
[Laughter]
so so we're saying that the move Knight
F5 is not a danger
in which position is a part of me in the
for for Russia versus nepo no I don't
think so because if you do go Knight F5
I have this idea of D5
you take on G7 but then I can just move
my vision right and the Knight is not
easily going out well I've got F5 don't
I have F5 protected
seven perhaps right
I can go Bishop D7 perhaps
so you go Knight to five I go D5 you
take on G7 I go Bishop D7
um by the way he said enough
I I refuse to uh to analyze the
positions of Knight F5 I'm just taking
this Knight on G3 off the board yeah
interesting decision yes why why the the
long think here everybody recaptures
towards the center Anastasia ah maybe
because he thinks to develop the bishop
somewhere else yes but normally I have
to do this move immediately right
absolutely
uh Christian I I'm just having a little
issues with my board for the moment but
just jump over to you why is Borussia
taking so long to recapture H2 takes G3
I do believe he took back yes he took it
with the H Pawn I would assume he was
considering after X G3 not capturing
towards the center to give this bishop
potentially another Square on F2 try to
put more pressure on the pawn on C5
after the bishop uh coming to F2 but
also to open up the file and activate
the Rook at the same time also you
already played the move C4 and D4 so is
that King actually going to Castle uh on
the queen side probably not so you want
to go on the other side with a pawn from
F to uh not in front of the king well
unfortunately that might make the
position of the king once it castles on
the king side week so that's what I
think uh he was trying to quantify in
his mind and try to understand the
nuances the details of the position as
we move further in the game and decided
to take with the horn which makes a lot
of sense to be honest it makes a lot of
sense not only that but sure you can
castle and get the king to G1 but also
you have this idea of potentially uh
starting an attack via the age while
activating the route that way with the
move route to H1 it just feels healthier
to take back with the age more by the
way I think we have a very funny
position going on in the Lavon versus
Wesley game as we're seeing both Bishops
capture enough H2 and H7 uh very very
funny uh setup at the moment uh and the
Bishops both retreating to C2 and C7
respectively by the way Gary what's the
story with Gary what's going on with
Gary
oops no moves
night G3
wow what's happening exactly like why is
he shaking because this move remember we
checked what the most there was this
movie I think Gary's having the same
problem I'm having he's he's looking at
this position and he's saying Knight on
G3 to F5 is a severe problem and I don't
like having to face that uh okay but
other people you just spend almost no
four minutes right now oh no that's
terrible time clock mismanagement that's
yeah let's not forget we have only 20
minutes for the game it's rapid chess
and it's really important to how you
manage your time 20 of your time just
poof out the window out the window move
one I mean you cannot do that no no no
no wait were you was time travel a
problem for you in your personal
absolutely yes yes I'm also this type of
person who likes to think about it yes
and it's never enough for me uh to
double check and triple check so I
understand really well with linear when
he's thinking yeah yeah I have to make a
move okay
and Shaq is smirking and he's like wait
what's happening uh
um maybe he's you know there was a game
Shakira played with um very Casper Maybe
Christian do you remember that it was a
very very short game and mommy said in
his interview that I was waiting for
this game so many years and then when it
happened it finished so quickly yes so I
mean well if Gary is so worried about
Knight F5 just play just seven and five
or Knight F6 right well you well to stop
Knight F5 I'm saying if he's so afraid
of this move Knight F5 you can just go
F5 yourself and just say okay your night
night's not going anywhere I'm gonna go
E6 I'm gonna go Bishop H5 I'm gonna go
Knight F6 I'm gonna get my pieces out
F5 looks great actually Bishop to G
three Knight F6 castles King side this
night will come to F7 and stop with this
10 minute thinking but this just comes
back to my Point earlier on is not about
the fact that he's not in shape he just
cannot make decisions actually pointed
out something very interesting he said
that Gary is famous to try to find the
best moves in general yes and sometimes
it doesn't help him and fish are random
because actually there are not really
best moves and you cannot really find
all of them you know you just have to
move on and finally we have a move wow
it took him how much time it's close to
Six Minutes close to Six Minutes yes to
me is opening that's just terrible
terrifying and you know he's he's being
plagued by self-doubts because of his
score I mean uh his play has been at
times very good at the Times poor but
it's just a score is is making him
reflect well including the opening move
uh Lavon aronian versus Wesley so this
was this funny funny game where the
Bishops were both capturing on H7 and H2
things haven't calmed down with this
last move d2d4 as Levon essentially is
throwing down a gauntlet here are you
going to capture on D4 and allow Knight
takes D4 Queen takes G2 do you want the
pawn Wesley
nice 93 or Knight G3 and it's upon
sacrifice
but I would be scared to take that oh
wait a minute wait a minute
you know it's a funny a funny thing I I
I tried to set up this trap
and attacking your queen but you
unfortunately you could trade queens and
make me reflect about how good my Pawn
sacrifice well look at Wesley D4 D5
wow just to you uh Christian let's go
best move in the position best move in
the position yes absolutely D5 oh my
goodness in fact this was C takes D4 and
queen takes G2 was extremely dangerous
not only because of Knight to G3 Knight
to G3 Bishop takes G3 and actually take
back with the F Pawn you can take on F1
but after Queen to A5 you simply don't
have height to secure your king Knight
to B5 is coming you have to defend the
A7 Pawn otherwise the queen gets too
close to your king and unfortunately you
are not in time there's too many threats
in the position if you go D6 I just pick
up the A7 Pawn your queen is not playing
not none of these pieces are playing on
the king side your kick is going to be
so he decided to go D5 good move great
move immediately challenging the center
as it is wow I mean obviously this is a
symmetrical position so white has an
extra tempo
white has to be better how much better
is the question right and we're going to
have to wait and see how these players
are going to develop this
Christian only time only time will tell
us
very good very good let's jump to
Fabiano for a second as he is uh up
against the defending champion of our
Fisher 9lx Bobby opened with the C4
English C5
that's what I was saying that look Gary
if you want to play
you know just play F5 and look we've got
the very same kind of position Fabi put
the Knight on F2 very nice obviously he
is about to Castle I think I would have
saved the move Knight F2 but okay and we
have a game of a very different game but
uh I'm still stunned that that Gary
spent so many moves uh there's so many
minutes uh making his first move sorry
let's just quickly catch up with Gary
not too much has happened but at least
he sped up his play his last move was
Knight G6 I'm seeing a lot of similarity
across some players have included C4 C5
most players have included C4 C5 some
have included F4 as well as yes
outside of only Fabiano who started off
with this move F2 F4 after C4 C5 Carl
also did something very similar as well
start started off with Knight to G3 but
it doesn't change that much and I have
to say I'm quite enjoying White's
position after the trade Bishop to F3
let's keep going Queen to C3 I'm ready
to Castle right now you still have to
get your Bishop out of the way and I
have to say look at that bish1 F3 right
now is so powerful right a lot of
pressure on the B7 pawn and once you
play the move Bishop to C6 well sure
we're going to exchange the Bishops but
you're going to lose some time and we're
going to exchange it on my terms you're
going to take on F3 and I will take back
with the Knight and gain a Tempo he
decides to go with this move E5
the first instinct uh tells me that this
has to be too slow right too slow you
you you're trying to do too much with
the black pieces while in the meantime
I'm developing my pieces I can still see
a move such as D4 coming in very quickly
so for example what if I castle castle
on right now
right what do you do uh I assume I'm
supposed to develop finally yes yeah
finally developing I want a castle and
defend upon on G7 so that I can shut
down shut that last move out what H4
H4 you know I really yeah I really as
white I I really want to play Bishop H4
Jack that's what he's going for and the
problem of course is the Knight on G6
stops Bishop H4 check out of session you
can get an H5 and Bishop H4 you feel uh
the excitement as far as white is
concerned he will be having a lot of fun
this is getting dicey for a Peter I have
to say after this movie H4 maybe a
pleasant yes to play with this position
very unpleasant actually you know these
days
um players are asking for support of
their followers and viewers so hikara
was asking in his Twitter account like
uh I need some good energy from you guys
yeah so it looks like you got some I
mean Yasir how could you let's say get
some good energy like you would call to
your friends yeah I give Hans Neiman a
call and say yeah could you could I
borrow your your fan club for a little
while I mean
they need some help over here
what what what could Peter do could
could Peter play Knight E7
H5 the bishop is coming and I know it
looks a little weird
am I losing way too much time is this
too extravagant I think so I mean I'm
not even going to wash the engine
[Laughter]
you give up on the engine I think this
is deadly I mean you lost so many uh
yeah yeah and I've developed my pieces
on their ideal squares you did you did
there's no Castle no I think it's it's
just too bad yes sir
is something like with the move E5 I
mean now the D5 Square will be also like
weak right yes for some time like how
important is it in Fisher random I mean
do we still have all this yeah all of
the one you're trying to Castle right
things that yeah you're all the
wonderful things that you know about
Chess are true and fish are random
outposts yes now that we've played E5
and C5 we weaken the D5 Square so it
makes perfect sense to get rid of the
Defenders of that square
um so I think your mind over even Knight
F6 some somehow colors in the Square yes
yeah but one of the things about
outposts are you know the outposts are
really really good interestingly enough
for minor pieces uh and the best
outposts are usually for the night so in
this position we would love to see the
Knight magically make its way to D5
because the Knight is so far away from
D5 I think Peter felt he could get away
with his
play but he may have overestimated his
position Bishop went to C6 by the way
upon went to H5 Knight went to E7 Bishop
went to H4 what we thought Queen to E6
again Peter's thinking if I can just put
my king on G8
and nothing untoward could happen in the
next move or two I'll be fine and I
think that's true
accept one question what about Bishop on
B8 how we will bring him into the game
we will pray
please
he seems a bit confused I think what
he's anticipating is this move d4
yeah the queen is on E6 D4 D5 is coming
with tremendous consequences you know
the weird part I don't even Castle first
I don't need to Castle here with the
weird part is because I was expecting
the king to be on E1 I said no you can't
play D4
D4 okay you're you're threatening kill I
mean he so I'll take
what that's okay I'll take back take
take
the problem is once you take with the
e-pawn also my Rook is coming to E1
that's a problem
once I take yes once you open up the E
file my Rook is coming to E1 yes
and not only that but if you take on D4
my queen is getting to attack your G7
Square as well there's your tie down at
this point with the black pieces maybe
we can play E4 I mean just to try you
know let's go E4 yes so if you play D5
now I maybe it will take on D5 take on
D5 and then
yes even this let's let's look at this
so I take on D5 you take with a queen
and I go King
let's say King C1
is better but I'm afraid that even if we
take now on the three quinches or
something yeah maybe I'll just stick
back with the Knight I just came back
with the Knight but I must say uh at the
end of the day I'm left with two of my
worst minor pieces and I don't like this
for black I'm gonna have to do better so
D2 D4 is by far this might be the most
challenging uh in the position and he
played it D4
Hikaru is really always he's looking for
good interesting Solutions right D4 is
absolutely absolutely he he I think for
initiative he is just one of those
players that has that you know sixth
sense of of hitting and in this
particular case because the queen is on
E6 what Christian was saying is anything
that opens up the e-file The Rook will
land on E1 and that's a that's a very
well it's an absolute pin those are the
worst so let's try not to open the E5
let's go E4 and play basically the same
variation but without opening the E file
E4 the bishop Zoom so no more D5 yeah no
more D5 for this one
but we but I am threatening D5 and queen
takes G7 a line Anastasia give me the
pawn I'm very exactly queen of seven to
protect from both rats okay but now
dangerous oh you can I can cancel oh
yeah
yes because this bishop
we want to take on their castle with a
check castles that's nice oh that's nice
now now I'm in trouble oh boy oh the
picture we cannot Castle under check so
this is yeah yeah the rules
um that's a problem
this is looking good for your car I just
want to go back to
um our tournament leaders and see how
farugia and nepo are getting along
that's just a game of chess
it looks like it came out of an open uh
sicilium it's just normal Greenwich too
okay let's see how they played fast uh
what what are the clock times uh
Anastasia yes let's check the clock here
there's only one player that played fast
okay so um actually you're right I'm at
seven sixteen minutes
walking around like it's no problem
I've got this I mean he's four out of
four the strategy is working it's really
fast and good
actually if you think about it it
doesn't work with have you ever done
that
I mean usually when you're in shape you
play faster but I play fast and good I
meant I'm typically not a fast player so
fast and good that's quite difficult but
Nepal we know that we know that he's a
fast player he plays like that in normal
chess as well he tries to put as much
pressure on his opponent as possible I
remember a game he played against nisi
Pano and uh that's a 2700 level Grand
Master he obliterated him out of the
opening with and finished with more time
than what he started off with so he can
do this type of Feats in Nepal yeah he's
the one of the best chess players in
Blitz and Rapid chess of course and it's
very very well known for that but
sometimes what I know also that
sometimes he can play too fast and miss
something it's very difficult to find
this balance always to play fast at the
same time not to do some even minor
mistakes so today I think he really does
well so far so good okay here's my
thinking Anastasia as black I
desperately desperately desperately want
to play the move F5 so that my room will
land on F2 with Force but I have to
defend the pawn on F5 I could play G6 F5
and then take or I like this Tempo
Gainer how about this check
and queen drops back to H5 the idea is
nice
I'm assuming the King has to move and
now I get in my this is my trick to get
into F7 F5 break
as soon as possible it feels like
this is a very yeah very dangerous
attack uh
for uh black maybe I could go back on G1
okay just back here like uh yes you gave
me second give one king F1 Queen went
back to H5 I'm just gonna go oh he just
played F5 right away yes also the same
story yes but I just don't like my king
only two let's say Okay King back to G1
maybe there is Queen then there's F5 yes
this is this is the the dream that I'm
having that The Rook will magically land
on that yeah by the way F5 right away uh
he can do the same variation here maybe
yes that's fine and was F5 the most
accurate move uh Christian and now Queen
F5 it was a normal movie yes yes not a
bad move Queen to G3 was played and then
we have the trade of the Queens once
again we're it seems like we're entering
an endgame in which most likely is going
to finish uh you know draw now one
player that's having huge problems right
now as we're speaking is Gary Castro
four minutes on his clock and a really
perilous position four minutes four
minutes only on his clock again 16
minutes for Muhammad yarov wow
okay this is the move Bishop to F4 he
spent 10 minutes on that move guys 10
minutes
Bishop to F4 and E2 E3 is actually
useful for the first player it is it it
it doesn't make a lot of sense I have to
say
oh my goodness his time Spencer right
now unfortunately is suffering nuts well
uh but you say it's dangerous but if
Gary can play Bishop C6 and castles
short
isn't he okay or am I missing but you're
still fighting against the two Bishops
true sure maybe you're going to be okay
but strategically for the long term
that's a problem I can just simply
castle castle short white white white
white has more pressure in the center
and the two Bishops and sasia so we have
one more time unfortunately it almost
feels like and the weather
and it's and it's a sunny day yes but
you know sometimes it happens like a
circle like first you think too long and
you you're not happy with your decisions
then another moment and you are again
you're disappointed and it's really hard
to play and find the best moves when you
already did something wrong in your game
but let's still hope that Gary will
fight cover yes uh Queen D2 as sets up
something kind of nice along the D file
so like if you playing Bishop C6 his
idea is that
he he
Shaq once something of this nature where
D6
is uh the issue it's unclear if in that
particular case works but just because
we have Queen takes Queen D2 King E7
King E7 whoa
there's no more castling for Gary
I didn't see that one coming
that looks like a No-No okay maybe if
you can take it that is not good I don't
we cannot do this no you can't do this
uh there should be some immediate
punishment I'm I I'm reaching for the
bee Pawn but and I stop myself because I
did see Bishop A4 so let's Castle first
yes absolutely that's the thing
sometimes you have to play simple jazz
can I
try to say no that's what queen takes D4
Queen takes D no no no
I even as I'm reaching for the pawn on
C4 look what what I'm doing okay so I'll
give it to you all right
Queen dito let's go that's all I ask
that's all I asked
I know what you want so I'll give it to
you
but you're gonna get you're gonna get
great compensation maybe even a huge
Advantage as well I I'm not I'm not
pleased I just say just being told that
Lavon is doing very nicely
uh here Rook just landed on E7 oh dear
that's a visual wow one more what if the
Knight takes up and we're getting it
back wow I'm kind of impressed that this
night
stayed yes yes
[Laughter]
um so how's the position after the
typical exchanges Knight takes C7 plus
Bishop takes seven let's take on g2s
foreign that's a visual I think you have
to take my Rook
okay
I don't have the 91 Bishop C7 the the
the time to do this look at this Knight
on H1 protecting it
that's why he was absolutely Jesus okay
okay so what which line would you like
to go with Christian no I think maybe
Knight takes G2 Let's uh
simplifies yes okay take only seven and
then someone first
sure why not why not why not and I
assume I want to take the Rook that
makes your life more yeah and now Rook
G1 probably right yeah and now I will go
Rook h8 oh look at shade
um
the night will be hanging
try to take advantage of that silly
night on H1 it is a pretty silly night I
must say looks looks okay for Wesley if
you ask me somehow it looks okay yes
more or less the ending will be like
four against four probably just let's
jump back to our tournament leaders
because they are they find themselves in
a four Rook ending in the last move just
a second two versus two
but that's four versus three pardon me
uh
so last move some captures going on
and broke F2 is a threat massive threat
massive threat
um
holy smokes
I'm
G4 by Ali Reza inviting Rook on F
a to F2 and even though
it's really really reduced material
I think the apple is for choice right
maybe it's like room d8 and then Rook H5
King G6 I'm trying to counter then Rook
H2 in the end I think it's Rook of five
and that's why he played this is so
clever Rook H5 King G6 then Rook G6 and
then Rooker five maybe exceptions
that is so clever oh very very nice
yeah I've only done but it also makes
space for the king to go to G3 so it's
definitely an improvement yeah I I'm
sure nepo underestimated this one so
once again if I go down and I go down
this whole variation
and let's see how we got here once more
up to six
and this is this is The Rook F5 yeah
but don't do this it's pretty dangerous
to have two Rooks on the second rank so
absolutely exchange it so can Napa avoid
allowing this
a rook trade because he sure would like
to play the position with four Rooks oh
she's still he goes for this okay well
let's see he it's going to happen
quickly yeah
it's going to happen very quickly The
Rook is coming to F5 with a check
which will
trade off the the the trade so how is
the king and pawn and Game King and Paul
yes so King F7 yes he's done king of
seven Rook F5 and now King E7
Rook F5 and then King E7 yes
he didn't consider it all he didn't even
consider it he didn't even consider it
he just went directly for the pawn down
Rook ending and he's saying I think I
can draw this because the king is active
yes yeah your king is not exactly not
yet
time's not a factor because uh netball
has been playing super fast 12 minutes
11 minutes for Napo two minutes for
alireza Ali raise upon up trying to win
and stop the the express train that is
nepo four out of four yeah Gary down to
his last one minute okay as we is before
okay too early to call this a draw or
you think probably not but I think we
will have time to come back to this one
all right Gary down to his last minute
he might be in trouble right now when we
left it we just saw the move Queen D2
King E7 and we all said what what what
king E7 takes and this is what I was
afraid of this bishop getting and look
at that I mean that is just such a
tender tender Pawn just success oh my
no this is all one-way traffic I mean
we've got ideas of Knight F5 check and
queen takes E5 20 seconds we've got I
forces Gary gets off good move this
diagonal
yes very good prophylactical move
but
Anastasia two Bishops good uh better
development what are we talking about
here this is yeah this is looking
terrible it's a good move but
unfortunately in a bad position there's
no good moves
um
the good move in a bad position yeah but
still you have to keep the position
let's see Bishop C2
okay and the bishop did drop back to D7
now Gary is a gifted Sicilian player put
a bishop on esophage and
we're talking about a reasonable
position but he no Bishop yes no no
square Bishop I think it's it's asking
too much but for the moment perhaps can
you go F4 right now
um
where's the night going well okay I'll
fall for it you don't want to take the
pawn like he's inviting you to take the
point yes of course yes of course you
can I mean that's a critical move
yes um no we have to suffer for
something at least yes if possible
exactly you understand me completely
Anastasia you're going to suffer at
least suffer with something okay let's
take something we've got to talk again
we're suffering for a pawn and we've got
Knight D5 on tap I go B3
somehow I felt it's not I don't know I
don't know
that's all you got simple together I
think this might actually be over and if
you go B5 yeah
um I think I just sidestep your B4 with
Bishop B2 and
you still cannot get out of the pin you
do what Bishop like Bishop B2 so okay
now you have D5 not D5 no it's our turn
yes now it's getting uh dicey no I don't
like this okay okay mystery so B3 he
said I like my part yes I don't want to
give it so easily but wait a minute
can I play B5 and Chase that Bishop that
is a very good question
he only has 10 seconds right now 10
seconds on his clock come on Gary just
play the flag guys I think we're down to
the five yes but how much time it must
be a second or two perhaps five seconds
oh
[Music]
B5 oh
that was at least it's going to force
Shaq to uh think a little bit here
because if we can chase this bishop away
or take a pawn we suffer the big
question is can you go Bishop takes D6
right now
probably that looks like a combination
that kind of plays itself doesn't it I
takes D5 you still have Queen C5 yes
because Knight C7 but now I have 96
Knight B7
oh okay but go to C7 you get two Pawns
and It's Tricky I mean this tricky is a
three result position yeah I think so
nice I mean I think White's better just
because I don't know
before first time
um
10 seconds for Gary right now 12. well
not anymore but that's 12 seconds goes
by in a nanosecond it's not right now it
has 11 seconds on his clock after this
move 66.
okay still I think white is just
overwhelming these Bishops are just all
he needs to do is kind of just make sure
that the form keeps he's trying to go
Queen G5
86.
but he's done it in a very nice way he's
kind of got a maroxy bind after Queen E2
white will go Queenie to double Rooks on
the D file and these two Bishops will
just sweep the board by the way
breaking news Hikaru is as one winning
gifts wins again that's two out of two
for Hikaru he's warming up
oh pardon me what yes it was Peter
oh oh
it's collapsing oh this is not looking
good guys and then 96 and Bishop B5 will
take on C5 right so yeah Knight just six
wow
game is over guys oh that's that's easy
oh oh
you likely he was even losing that but
uh it he never got out of the opening
what can I say uh
no why why not
that King is really stuck on G8 I think
it was white who has who had this the
problems
wow I mean you have to go A6 but now I
can even consider King E4
King E4 will defend the pawn on F5
making the threat so Rook B7 Rook takes
F5 you and actually defends against
Checkmate if it defends it against
Checkmate but once you play the move
King E4
the move the thread of Rook B7 is I
still think you probably have to go
towards this route to B7 move so but
first start with King to D4 King to
David four sure
okay defend the pawn on C4 what do you
play
action
I don't see a good one okay one for
example what will happen just because
seven yes
for free yes and if you don't take on F5
I think you're just done well I mean I
don't like this King on G definitely
but now I go Rook B7
B7 Rook you take on F5 I take on B6
and you're threatening my a pawn and I
always have this idea of Rook to B8 and
I think this end game if you allow me to
go root to B8 is already lost king of
Fate he plays protecting against
everyone F5
what if I take on B6 now which he is
about to do and then take the other guy
as well because we'll take on A6
upon an Asics here right that's a pawn
to the good then you still have some
problems with the G7 part I don't know
guys this looks like might be a win a
technical win already for white
okay I think uh you're making a very
good point here and he definitely Ali
razor just hacked that pawn off the
board well he hacked it because he only
has 12 seconds what a great play by
Liberation auditioning yes yeah and
first he defended against those ideas
with Rooks on second Rank and now
actually he's proven the descending
exactly
and that was perfect uh tournament may
be coming to a screeching halt well he's
definitely not winning this one no
uh pardon me there is a there is a clock
Factor no no definitely not it happened
once but there's no way I'm jinxing
these ones
commentator's curse is powerful
[Laughter]
okay let's
start pushing now okay if you uh
I was about to say I'm cutting off the
king if I could play King this is over I
think this is just completely rookie
sixth no that's really cool that's just
a killer move that's over yeah no Rook
F5 was terrible because
uh this move just ends the game but you
don't have time to get out with the King
unfortunately yeah well you don't have
King E7 I think why because I go check
on A7 and then if I go King F6 Rook F7
and if I take in game is lost aren't I
in the Square I'm not sure if you are so
I take oh you go King D5 go King D5
first yes
what and I checked and I've yeah but now
I go King D6 and now I need to push C5
and I have Queen I think
he wanted us to find all this I'm sure
yes sir has already calculated long time
ago I admire the fact that yeah
I just failed it and there it is resigns
oh my goodness and let's quickly go to
this game uh our defending champion
Lanier Dominguez uh defending
wow defending defending
these this is looking very very good for
Fabi but is it though yes okay H5 is on
the board H5 Bishops of opposite color
why is it so good coming up
but that Bish that pawn on F6 I can
defend with I'm not convinced I go E5
immediately aha so you go Knight F6 you
we exchange and then I go E5
okay so once again so no no yes
looking to play yes G4 I was about to
say maybe Knight H3 is a bad news I mean
are we really sure that white is that
much better in this position
complicated
if you don't know I mean I thought that
Knight F6 if I could have got that
Bishop's above is a color with the pawn
on F6 protected I would like white his
chances but he didn't actually achieve
it I think the problem is this Knight on
F2 has no has not got really good square
and uh linear played this G4 move key
link with the opportunities for this
night so just to give you an update on
the other game uh Wesley actually
managed to Swindle Levon and is right
now winning his game oh
good news for you guys
the Restless fighting he's an influencer
I mean he wait who's the influence
you use that Jedi mind trick of yours I
I knew you wanted to eat Wesley
I did from the start but yeah you just
kind of somehow confirmed it
now I'm thinking about an idea
such as follows E4 9193 and then Knight
D5
E4 something like that
91.91 for this night try to
scare you to death
I know you're not going to get scared
not easily but scared for sure no but
you know what this one if you play 94.
92 windy too by the way you know kind of
invited that whole concept that you were
saying Queen F5 E4 he just wanted to
make sure that his Queen would control
some uh dark swear this move G5 seems to
me like a very very good but now D4
the move that you try to play to open up
the D file you put the queen on the D
file open it up D4 Knight and now E4 but
now on Knight E4 you take on D4 okay I
understand
but that's ugly you just you you just
self-inflicted wounds it is but your
pieces are also not playing that is true
your pawns your bad pawns cover a lot of
good good stories on the board
yeah I know my guy G4 okay okay
oh
sorry
right now if I go Queen to D3 what do
you do queen to D3 check
probably I hide my king so you don't go
Knight to five
I'm not trying to fall for my little
trick I was a little bit afraid that
there might be some D5 exactly dirty
that was my trick dirty tricks
you know your guy oh my God he's going
for the dirty tricks the dirty tricks
and they're done they're cheap queen G6
wait a minute G6 E4 he played so he's
going for the same type of setup do you
know the queen on G6 maybe it's worst
place then that's why I was thinking
that the King on H6 actually might have
been the queen when the queen was on F7
we could have like slipped around and
hit this Pawn okay
um
this Knight on F2 doing great work
this Knight on G7 looks terrible 98
Knight E8 let's try to improve look not
so much time falling here only seven
only yeah with two seconds on his clock
yes
trying to focus on the weaknesses
ig7 gain some seconds actually did not
gain any seconds still seven seconds on
the clock I don't think uh Lanier has
actually played this very well at all
there was also a move Queen d8 there
that I really despised Queen d8 Bishop
takes Chief and queen the 80 was afraid
of Bishop takes E4 I know and then
Bishop takes F6 Bishop takes G5 and
Bishop F6 P3 I like this move you do the
Knight is finally having a very serious
question that is to go to Checkmate the
black yeah G4 was played okay Knight G5
King G8 and now let's get the queen to
d8 Queen D4 Queenie
or queen A3 Queen Seven that's more
visual
queen queen
think he missed it I think Queen A3
there but maybe he wants Bishop B4 was
good that's what he wants yeah before
nicely spotted
yes yeah he wants to give a Checkmate on
f8 and then you cannot defend with Queen
H6 the problem is he's defending this
wait so passively but now Queen F6 right
yes we have six Queen H6 and there is a
Checkmate sighting on H7 I don't think
you defend against that
Queen to H6 not so sure because you have
Queen H5 Bravo linear is defending so
well cannot believe it incredible
defense by linear yes with no time as
well no
15 versus 15 seconds right now wow now I
don't know okay but White's pieces are
dominating that pawn on e4 is just
playing this fantastic role they have
some resources like Bishop before
sometimes maybe give up this bishop and
maybe watch out for Knight H5
keep going with the King
but look at White's complete domination
on the dark screen it's it's so powerful
this bishop is perfectly anchored the
queen on F6 is so
powerful keep going with the King right
King E3 yes okay secure the king
24. now that we're here we might as well
defend our Pawn
oh my gosh not easy still Yes six
seconds for Fabiano he needs to make a
move come on
should be winning with those phones no
for sure
for sure because he's also got oh I was
about to say he has Bishop C7 but he put
his Knight in the The Way of the bishop
Knight D5 don't trade those Knights
Knight E7 blunder alert
you're losing either the B6 Pawn or the
bishop
that was a good move Knight takes B6
though
Knight takes B6 Bishop takes E4 Knight
back to E4 and the C pong makes a
triumphant large
he's done it
and not come back
ah he played C5 without playing Knight
Knight D5 would have come with the tempo
Knight F6 I'm I'm really stunned that he
he didn't put his Knight on E7 so he
could go C5
the technical task is getting difficult
right now no it's still well it's extra
pounds right King B4
Bishop C6 Knight A5 be careful what D5
perhaps Wesley so one
uh Wesley saw drew his game against
LeBron wow that was a roller coaster
okay there goes Pawn number three
and it support not to play King B5 no
why not disarray
in some ways I see that's enough you
don't need to do it yes it just came
before okay
and now we just get the pawn to A5 three
points
should be enough and that Bishop on D6
is protecting absolutely right
a bishop diesel The Bodyguard yes but
perhaps black can give up all their
pieces for um and we will see Knights
and bishop checkmate
never know I don't think you have enough
pieces to give it for all three parts
sometimes you can give food for two
eight five you know A5
I think we should go A5 I think A5 but
then even
if we get our Pawn to A6 uh then we can
go Bishop to B8 so we put our Pawn on A6
and then we can go Bishop to B8 wait a
minute
93 or what
yes wait a minute what is he done Bishop
sees
aren't you losing a pawn right now he
might be losing Bishop C7 five might
have been premature things are getting
murky that's not so much time again
oh my goodness there goes a pawn oh no
oh my goodness now we've got Goods four
chances for a fortress
this might especially with of course the
color Bishops night to come on Lanier
you put your knight on C6 and nine nine
out of ten cases it's all about the time
right now guys Bishop to F1 Knight to F4
setting up this E6 move
and where the bishop actually and this
thing is allowed the pawn to get to E6 I
don't know this might be if he had put
his Knight back on C6 he could have
played Knight to d8
195 right now
go with Knight to F6 but well Knight C7
check E7 not quite on the menu let's go
Knight C7 right now and then push the
king
to d8 where you want to put the King on
the way down after that
defending on E6 and then just start
moving with the King you need to use
your King right now of course absolutely
but the problem is what if I give you a
check where do you go oh yes anytime you
go to guys this is
actually not easy no maybe now triangles
yes okay King goes to F6 or what maybe
then E7 yes on the king side don't like
that the only thing I see now it's the
king coasters I think he wanted to go
the other side but then he realized not
so easy let's go to the to the Kingston
King E3 yes
I like I'd like the bishop on
97 is a nice trick if you take only
seven King takes E7 is probably a draw
actually it is a draw okay so that's a
good move by linear is he threatening
Knight D5 chat yes seven seconds
absolutely
he was definitely threatening that and
now Bishop to H3
no no Bishop huh
okay so Knight D5 same idea
okay doesn't want any Bishop it's a
toxic color that is Bishop F5 which by
five Knight D4 ah thank you
I think he's he's probably going to get
this done guys
three seconds
with one second on his clock
notice of Steel you need to have to play
this game let's go King G4 yeah but
you're absolutely right uh you need
great nerves wait a minute but now I can
take on King of five no this is over
and that was enough
once again guys the 80 ratio and that
game with Lavon Wesley I was getting all
kinds of different I was it was a win it
was a draw it was a loss
everything just happened everything
happened real free love oh this should
be a win for black right I think that
was the critical moment actually if we
take it all the way we're looking on D3
and King on A3 yeah I think right now
the move was Rook to E3
Rook to E3 I believe so yes and isn't
that a pretty one or perhaps instead of
one three five film I like discovered
instead of Rook to E5 actually so Rook
to E5 allowed Rook to B5 once you take
on B6 now I have to go to E3 Rook to E3
now yes not easy just to push your King
backwards right right and then just
escort the F pushed upon yeah yeah so
for example if you take on uh if you go
Rook to B5 then I can just simply push
oh
that's the thing
Rook F5 is always going to be met with
check with check so you don't have time
to get anywhere close to me
very nice yes I remember the drugs you
have to put them behind the only thing I
remember
your training is paying off very very
nicely but some of this round for us
Christian four decisive games just a
wild round and let's take a look at the
results right now Anastasia we have a
tie and we have a tie exactly
are tied for the first place by winning
this game jumped on the First on pie
right and then we have Fabiano caruano
and Shakira mediaro with three and a
half points followed by Leo and Hikaru
Nakamura with three points
um Wesley so two points linear Dominguez
one and a half and then we have Peter
swindler and Gary kasparo at the end of
the table with a half a point for Peter
and zero points so far for Gary it's
been a very very tough event for Gary is
he spent guys five minutes on a move
zero I mean he just he didn't have an
excuse me you cannot do that yeah you
cannot spend 25 percent of your time on
move one before move one interesting
you're not going to recover from that so
unfortunately Gary is really struggling
but one player that is surging right now
is Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru just won his
first two games and we know what
happened in the blitz section during the
St Louis rapid and Blitz he can string
these victories together and potentially
get very very close within Striking
Distance right now to the top of the
leaderboard so definitely a player to
watch
and round six coming your way do we have
pairings for that yet uh Anastasia I
hope so
we will think about it otherwise I can
actually check them here because right
now we've been seeing the two top Rivals
play against each other in round four
and round five just tell us oh here
again I would have them yes great thank
you so Wesley is so Place against Gary
casparo the only problems actually has
three and a half points now players are
doing very well yes
our surgeon Golden Boy exactly and Peter
sweetler against Fabi and we have 11
aronian playing against Hikaru Nakamura
wonderful and that's all coming up on
the other side of this break
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
Direct
this one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways and is home to the U.S
and World Chess Halls of Fame Cutting
Edge exhibitions feature rare historic
chess artifacts paired with world-class
art Innovative programming explores the
intersection of Chess art and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everyone we have current
standings after round five and yesterday
we have co-leaders right now absolutely
yeah
you were hearing about it and I was
going Anastasia
alireza absolutely yes actually managed
to beat Jan in the previous round and
now he is tied for the first place
for the third place together with
Shakira my media over three and a half
points and then we have leonardian we
see Carl Nakamura both of them have
three points Right Wesley stock has two
uh one and a half points bittersweiler
half a point and Gary kasparo so far
didn't manage to make on the scoreboard
no not at all and round six pairings
Anastasia has set the table for us for a
final round of the day Wesley Seoul will
play against Gary Kasparov Yani punish
she will face Shakira manitiaro Menards
English sure yes very important game
right so right standings and linear
Domingos will play against
our sweet little faces Fabiano caruana
live on arunan against Hikaru Nakamura
that's going to be a big matchup I'm
really looking forward to the Yan versus
chat game but also the Lavon Fabi as we
see the Golden Boy with the golden shoes
the easy easy does it shoes uh what can
you say he's winning everything
Christian
including now the 960. I mean after this
one he's moving to St Louis for sure
he is going to make this his base this
is going to be his favorite city for the
rest of his life I mean he made enough
money for a lifetime in two weeks are
you kidding me yeah he's going to go
over three hundred thousand dollars in
two weeks that's not bad that is
fantastic and by the way it looks like
they have a reveal I wonder if we can't
do it ourselves Anastasia shuffle them
up and tell me what position they're
going to play yeah let's check it so we
have position
852.
again quizzer and the corners yes A1 and
A8 squares so let's have a look these
shops are over the week squares week
squares so let's find them
it's only those guys and Christian break
down the position for us what do you
think the bad pieces are this is a
difficult position guys the way I see it
both nights are actually in a very very
difficult situation because if you look
at the Knight on H1 most likely the
natural spot is to go to G3 absolutely
but after that how are you going to open
up the bishop on G1 if you do go F3 I
can see ideas of potentially a black for
example against nitrog3 playing moves
such as F5 and then trying to go F4 and
make it difficult for Knight on G3 find
the right placement perhaps you want to
be thinking about ideas of starting off
with F3 instead of Knight to G3 and
potentially getting the Knight to F2 and
closer to the center via that square F2
that also allows you to open up the
bishop G1 now another question big
question in the position is what are you
going to do with an iPhone C1 so these
are the two pieces that right now to my
eyes look at the most uh I'm comfortable
in this starting position problematic as
there we get a very very good bird's eye
view of these special pieces they're
made from the by the house of stone
designed by Frank camerata and I gotta
tell you when you're there at the board
you're sitting behind these pieces it
feels like there's a work of art in
front of you and you want to create a
masterpiece with these pieces they're
really really beautiful they're triple
weighted and as far as the sinkhill cap
goes you could bid on these pieces and
own a piece of history as the players
are getting underway and your first
impressions why Anastasia are there's so
many decisive games in the fish are
random compared to say rapid and Blitz
maybe because we don't have Berlin
[Laughter]
yeah how can you overcome the Berlin of
course but I think Levon uh specified it
in yesterday's interview it's so easy to
get a winning position after like three
moves with the not necessarily winning
but a better position with the black
pieces after three moves so this
positions are so imbalanced because the
players don't have they have 10 minutes
to prepare for the game right what are
you going to do in 10 minutes you're
right to scratch the surface if that
right so you're not going to understand
exactly what's happening on the board
and that's why we're seeing so many
imbalanced positions and so many
decisive advantages out of the opening
that's what leads to uh having so many
decisive games and they're the players
are getting ready for this our sixth
than final round does Levon have a
normal shirt
[Laughter]
I don't think so here he's uh he he's
sporting a kind of uh
bifurcated look
I mean
and actually I'm thinking about Hikaru
probably already in his mind he's
creating comments for today's recap in
the evening you know already about two
games something to speak about right
today so E4 E5 F3
not the king's Gambit that we're used to
new version of the new version
like really modest Kings combat correct
I like these I want to be too aggressive
um
with my board how is it going with your
with yours my boards are updating yes so
I don't have anything for that so Wesley
F3 because Bishop C5 cannot come now
F4 is a leading choice we have three
games that started with the same couple
of moves I think the 45 F3 in Iranian
versus uh Hikaru Dominguez also started
with the same setup and Wesley against
Gary started with the same setup as well
F3 F6 Knight G3 and right now is Gary's
uh move in this position hopefully he's
not going to be spending another five
minutes on his first couple of moves uh
definitely an intriguing situation Peter
has started off with a completely
different approach F4 at move one it
does look a bit more aggressive right
right you're trying to gain as much uh
space as possible potentially hinder
Black's development with the move E5
this seems to be key in this position I
don't even know what compare it with
some sort of a reverse Sicilian in
position 287 or whatever the position
that we have on the board right now it
is it looks like a reverse Sicilian of
some sort in my opinion after move e45
Blake created the threat to play Bishop
C5 maybe sometimes I'm not sure so maybe
F3 was the idea to actually protect
against the bishop C5 so in the game of
linear versus
for example E4 E5 what you said and then
the move F3 was to stop black from
playing Bishop C5 situations now that's
a great Theory until you see the next
move that uh faru Japan
blocking blocking the bishop but okay
look I mean it's obvious that white is
pressing for the move d2d4 and it makes
a lot of sense that black would want to
put the Knight on C6 by the way Castle
once again B5 once put the Knight on C6
how do you get the queen out
the queen on A8 because I do feel like
you want to Castle long right so put the
King on C8 and right it's a very short
Castle the long Castle let me put one
move on the board for just a second
because this is actually you're going to
start immediately with D4 yeah yeah that
makes a lot of sense
D5 maybe Knight G6
how are you gonna defect an idea all
right
D3
right she said yeah I'm not sure I want
to do this though
let's continue with that four
and there was a lot of compensation I I
can see that don't forget there is uh
but what if I take now wait a minute I
take on D6
Bishop takes
now how do I defend this Pawn on F4 I
guess let's try it with G3
wow uh I can't for the moment
see exactly how I'm supposed to exploit
and I'm casting next move yes you are
but you do have Bishop to B for so maybe
this is still not over you still have
some compensation little Annoying tickle
there yeah but you make a very good
point once you've Castle the queen is in
trouble you don't want to play B6 to
allow Bishop on F1 to A6 and the bishop
actually controls A7 so that's not by
the by the way we do have can we confirm
that after Castle Lanier played King C1
and didn't Castle
really
97 night here no he counts Castle okay
and castle
so there was a king on see there was a
king on C1 but because the queen is on
A1 you kind of think hey wait a minute
you know like did he play games because
the Rook is not on anyone castles
castles as both players prep for D5 as
well as D4 now having the extra half ply
shouldn't it be better for white it
should be yes yes yes absolutely just go
D4 and play that position with the next
reply but we've seen a very similar
scenario in the game between aronian and
Wesley so in the last game and actually
aronian with the black pieces
um managed to equalize and not only that
he got the advantage out of the opening
so
it's dangerous to play to mirror things
like this yes
and uh Gary
he's off off the starting blocks at
least he didn't uh yes E4 E5 F3 F6
Knight G3 and Gary said you know what
I'm much more concerned about D3 D2 D4
than anything let me stop that right
away with the move C5 C3 and
we've caught up with the players they
haven't made that many moves I missed us
now
Wesley thinking
uh Wesley just played the move C3 so
Gary's thinking maybe maybe D5
it's nice to have the bishop on Jade
when you play Move C5 and E5 exactly
we still have D5 The Outpost that you're
creating for your opponent is defended
at once uh and let's just go around and
see what's happening Lanier versus
ferrugia so D5 when we're anticipating
that linear will want to play D4 himself
oops excuse me this is Lavon something
similar Hikaru the same direction as
Gary with the C5 and E5 and then another
one of our co-leaders this is the game
between nepo and Shaq okay Shaq says I
want to bring my queen out on the
diagonal let's see how they did this
this is a little bit funny F4
so Napo was the one who went D4 and F4
and uh controlling the E4 Square for the
moment and this is the first time
actually that I'm not seeing Nepal
dominating on the clock he is actually
down two minutes 16 minutes against 18
perhaps that last round defeat is accept
into his confidence a bit yeah actually
is in a good shape suddenly right I mean
he didn't have really great events in St
Louis and this is the first event when
he actually found finally his his way
yes he's also enjoying this type of
Chess we know him as a very creative
player a very attacking player so so far
so good for shock but I think it's a
very important game for him as well
absolutely I mean for the tournament
standings uh Shaq is just a half of or
behind the two uh tournaments co-leaders
alireza and nepo I like this move Bishop
to G2 immediately setting up to take
advantage of the fact that you played
the move PC
opening up the battery on the long
diagonal towards your queen so now E4 as
you are pointing out the other board
becomes a real threat in the position I
would probably want to lock it down
either with the move Knight E4 or maybe
with the move F5 in both cases I don't
like facing E4 I don't think that with
the Rook already
in Prime position I would really want to
stop E4 the problem with F5 is I feel
your knight on G6 is very badly played
at this place at the same time
it's a closed position and you have
enough time to potentially to maneuver
that night E5 whoa E5 okay that is
definitely a different approach all
together
yes what do we think about this move
guys first let's check what it would
take yeah I think it's just it's it it
feels like it should be dangerous
because whoa whoa whoa are we seeing
take take and E4 was was that the move
oops whoa
what therefore these guys are going at
each other guys right now oh
E4 they're not shying away for sure okay
so for me the move d4 takes E5 as
opposed to F4 takes E5 is a clear
indication that I am ready to Castle
Queen side and
take advantage of this
potential pin as well as a potential pin
along the e-file
I would be worried
in black shoes you do have castles
though yourself what about
five only four maybe 94 and then
I don't know you cannot do castling
actually 96 but yeah exactly yes because
now this bishop speed right the Knight
cannot move I mean it can't move but
then Queen G2
from the original position
oh sorry so E5 yes take take E4 maybe
we're allowed to take once Knight take
C4 and then no no takes before and then
black cannot do castling because Knight
D6 right
that's funny
with a discovery on your queen yes so we
cannot do it but white is not
threatening to take maybe on this
perhaps Bishop D5 is maybe yes yes
Bishop comes out and the problem is the
problem that I'm seeing right now is
that if you do go Knight takes D6
I think I can stop you from castling no
I think I have Bishop F3 first
Bishop of three nice
intermediates move and there's no more
castling right
you can take take but then if you put
the Rook on E2 then still you cannot
Castle because the Rook on it is going
to be a threat dude it looks nice do you
know that's visionzuk and zook Swang are
the two words that our producer knows in
chess oh really
it's self-mastery we call it
[Laughter]
yes uh Bishop F3 a good uh Visions well
thank you thank you very much yes uh
okay we're gonna keep an eye on this one
where is the action well Gary Gary Gary
is the action in this game because he's
pushing his pawns and he's going for it
right now he knows that he has
absolutely nothing to lose I I believe
in push him baby but I thought it was
push him in the ending not push him in
the opening push-ups he has an opening
guys he hasn't moved any pieces he
hasn't moved one piece
uh well to be frank why should we moved
his Queen a couple of times and the
Knight on G3 so it's not such a no white
has I'm talking about Gary right but
there's not much of a difference right
why didn't do as much either with any of
his Pieces Just Tonight on G3 shuffled
the queen around a little bit
okay yeah let's try to be positive
please I got it I'm trying I'm trying it
it's my move right now so okay Gary
what should Gary be doing Christian you
seem to have a handle on this Fisher
random stuff I I like the position let's
go Knight G6 right that's uh Knight G6
let's develop the pieces
let's develop the pieces you guys were
talking so much about development less
develop businesses
we show our our class our culture our we
never forget about principles in the
opening no no we are people of great
principles great culture and if you
don't like them we have others check
this move out I did like Bishop before
that's a nice move yes a moment ago
uh means we're not castling kingside and
in fact we were saying that black is
moving only his pawns but he was
creating threats
A5 had a clear threat Bishop to B4 right
you cannot allow that so you have to
lose some tempies yourself with Queen C2
now Bishop to B4 suddenly you have to
spend another 10B to Define The Rook on
E1 so right it does seem like black Gary
that is is catching up and also he has
so much extra space on the queen side
given by that thorn in White's position
the pawn on C4 and so much time by the
way yes yes I think first time today
we're seeing it yeah he's playing
quickly they're close yes great okay but
now with this I'm anticipating Rook E3
we can see that pardon me Wesley will be
looking at developing his Knight 92
Knight F5 his King is going to be a an
issue I can see that we might have to
play a2a3 to
what am I talking about you can't cancel
Rook what are we talking about oh yes
you are right guys Apple missed it what
nepo missed this bishop F3 move really
yes oh
so what happened well now he's in
trouble
ah so this is what happened after Bishop
to F3 he's in trouble yeah
we currently have on the board the
engine is saying black is completely
dominating right now let's take a look
at the camera and see his reaction
because I'm pretty sure he missed this
critical move Bishop
he doesn't look happy no so King went to
D2 but now you have to spend yet another
Tempo on getting out of this attack on
the bishop by the way this move Bishop
F3 does have the benefit at least uh
stopping uh queenside castles but you
can't black still play
short sure you can still go short Castle
yeah probably oh wait a minute this king
is just terrible Andy is that a passion
it's a very good Pawn any any Rook trade
King takes and King f8 I'll be safe
so B6 was actually what a move you know
to make sure that Queen is coming out
wow after his scorching 4-0 start nepo
had a hiccup in the previous round
he may be suffering a second success of
defeat he just played B4
what
here we go I mean sometimes you got to
be a little coffee house yes
the only thing I know
coffee house yes did he really yeah I
saw the movement of the hand I think he
played B4 okay let's see there's no way
he played C4 A4 doesn't make a lot of
sense yes probably the idea is to take
on G7 afterwards
and bring the pieces into the game maybe
it's a checkmating threat that we
decided to refresh no we don't have B4
on the board maybe we can see the bird's
eye view for a second that game that's
going to help us yeah you're right
there's a point on B4 Guys somebody
threatens your night and you say ah it's
okay let's go
I'm expecting castles
uh I just don't want to see Queen takes
G7 land on my doorstep rookie seven was
his decision he didn't take the night
rookie Rook E7 he could have castled
maybe he could have gone look inside
really easy to forget about it but wait
a minute guys go ahead go back to the
camera so let's go back to the camera
let's see what's going on with if you I
take the night Bishop to E6 Now and Then
followed by Bishop to D4 you have to be
careful ah you might be getting yourself
in trouble
on the long diagonal
thank you for explanation yes so Shaq uh
it has some Venom to it wow I like this
move before
B4 and Rook E7 on the board I believe we
have whoa Knight C5 I think we cannot
find any movement wait a minute
this cannot be a good movie if we were
just unpredictable if we'd be in deep
trouble how about Queen D5 check
sure
Queen E5 or take on C5 and then Queen D5
well I have an idea the idea so I go
King C1 I think is the only move oh okay
yeah
King to C1
and then what we take the Knight
we take the Knight we take the pawn but
the bishop is trapped The Rook is
hanging and there's a Checkmate on B8
yeah
bad news we have some news
and it's bad news okay so I don't take
on C5 that Knight on C5 is actually
complete garbage it's not doing anything
what how dare you yes yes I said it I
mean I'm the high priest of material and
garbage all right what if I take on F4
let's try for some
some some aggressive stuff
oh Knight takes F4 without the queen
check by the way but why is is that a
better version maybe the king cannot run
away I was a little bit worried about 96
so
Knight F4 so this is the variation I'm
seeing right now you take I take yes
King's history Bishop B5 I think you're
forced to go
no there's no way
why why why why I have Bishop D4
um
let's just put that on board because our
our best most centralized peace
don't say no no no don't say it
perfectly happy in the middle of the
board this is we're not getting checked
I'm just glad it's not me he took them
no there's no Queen D5 first he took the
night I'm gonna start with Queen D5
Queen D5 chat where do you put the king
well here I you're kind of giving me
interesting choices including both
Bishop D4 and queen D4
yeah you have Queen D4 I don't like that
um actually no because Queen D4 I take
on F4 and I think that's good Yes
actually King c3b should be five here
that is nice yes that is very good and
90 Bishop E3 Queen takes D4 just
correct so like Queen D4 now Bishop F4
if let's show maybe this one like 24 now
Bishop goes to F4 Bishop E3 yep you
think you defended but Queen D4 that's
embarrassing yes I have to uh go to C3
but you are already told the answer
when they see the king out
[Music]
um
hunting time my hunting time
wow wow wow I mean we've got a danger
for a person in the in in studio here
hunting time yeah hunting time wow
Bishop takes F4 I'm gonna have to play
Bishop E3 wait why not King C3
I mean we still haven't figured it out
right with your King on D4 I mean I get
it it looks funny but you you you you
want to you want to find I I still don't
see the Checkmate yeah that is a point
by the way he took on C5
just like that
which is a bit of a strange decision
if you forgive me I can't guess any of
the players move that's what the last
four or five moves it did uh it was
creative yeah mystery concrete it's too
crazy
Bishop takes Bishop takes F4 check
um
this is terrible
okay so what if I take with the pawn
okay show me the show me the main
what does it make
sure because now you gave me one extra
option if you do start with Queen D5 yes
I do have the move Queen to D4 now
and if you take on F4 I go King C3 and
then you still have to contend with the
Checkmate so you cannot do that you
don't have time for Bishop B5
yeah what an interesting difference
right maybe it's a huge difference well
I think white is winning at that point
so B takes C5 maybe black is forced to
play Bishop takes
so let's start with that one Bishop
takes yes and we do believe that King to
C3 is the only move
right
well uh Bishop E3 Bishop B3 Queen D5 and
Kings kc1 Bishop takes E3 and queen D1
and queen yes okay that's what it is
nice actually Queen D5
King she won
check thanks to this Rook controlling
the B2 Square
that's an Uninvited Intruder actually
it's like Mutual threat right from both
sides because
there's a check made of B8 and there's a
check made on D1 but you still have King
C3 so let's keep going so Kings history
take on F4 yeah
not Bishop E3 that's losing that's the
losing move
and by the way guys if Shaq wins this
one and btx C5 is on the board we might
be going into this variation if he wins
this he will have a perfect day three
hours three out of three you told me
that Hikaru is surging as well yes
two out of two so uh and Hikaru is
better in his game against Levon so
this is a hotly contested race right now
I have to say wow let's leave this one
alone and let's take a look at hikaru's
position oh he's about to make a move do
we really want to leave that thing
it just kind of stopped for a moment
there
Perugia linear is quite the mess Gary
Wesley
everything is a mess
I do have Bishop takes and King C3 on
the board guess what that Bishop that
King's gonna end up on D4 and stuff and
we're going to explain to you what
why leading with your king is not a good
idea I have an idea guys what if I start
with E3
E3 here
E2 E4 E3 it has some sense of course
because you uh yes
um
wow so many threads now uh right my the
the first move the instant first move I
don't know why was Rook check right and
I don't think I take that exactly I
think I go King E8 you probably just
sidestep and I was gonna try to block
but
I don't like it you've got Bishop here
yeah I was I was thinking of something
as mundane as this but but I don't have
to take that Rook I can go Queen D5
first precisely I'm worried about oh oh
yes yes I like the move E4 E3 I was just
I'm kind of a bit surprised in fact that
Bishop E5 Bishop D4 there's not a clear
win here
it do we really believe that Shaq is
just about to make a move yeah the only
thing which I was thinking also like if
we move the Rook from a seven then we
will never be threatened Checkmate all
this idea so maybe
ah you want to take on B1 first uh
because again see this bishop and this
queen but I go C6 versus this bishop and
this queen yeah I go C6 you cannot take
with the queen and if you take with the
bishop then you lose so many tempies so
what about rookie four first that's okay
my king is on C5 perfectly so no
perfectly safe come on guys
defending
and attacking yeah I know come on it's
equal rookie five King D4 is before and
we're going to have to sign the score
sheets
nobody believes you I think that King is
gonna get mated right in the middle of
the board how how about that oh that's
nice that's nice uh
but what if I go check check even even
at the end King C5 King here check on B8
okay and check on B4
and I'm telling
and by the way one of our co-leaders uh
alireza is doing great his way against
the linear
wow how's this first step family
undefeated player okay the tournament
yes I mean the only one who made only
two draws and he won all of the rest of
the games this kid is good you were you
were saying Anastasia that you had just
looked up the history and that uh in
fact Ali Reza had played in one of the
online yes 360 events he said before
that he has never played actually in in
the tournaments in St Louis but he
actually played once and probably he
wanted to forget about this event
because he came last he was a loss but
but it was online event the one which
Christian was mentioning today before
the at the very start yeah he played in
2020 in Fisher random and he the one
which Magnus won together with Hikaru
and he was lost last yes so from the
lowliest to the holiest but it was 2020
and two years well actually what kind of
progress he has made uh I'm going back
to the game of nepo and Shakira for a
moment because guess what
uh Shaq likes your choice uh very much
um
I mean Christians
they say the blind chicken can find a
corn
what what
Soulful Expressions
guys guys E3 is over E3 is it's it's
done it's over game over he can reside
let's move on to the next one
uh successive defeats after his 4-0
starts he has no tricks in the position
like that King is getting checkmated or
you're losing a lot of material
absolutely no tricks yeah
let's take a look at Nakamura guys
because okay he's the other player that
potentially could be going three out
three out of three and we just saw a
queen check let's just go back here for
a moment
take sticks check let's trade Queens but
on my terms absolutely yeah
so are we satisfied with that can we do
better than trading Queens
King B7
six
or you really want to do you really want
to allow me to yeah I mean it's just
like one of those very funny things
there is a standing mate but I do have
Knight to a five right to block
the file I get it you get okay seven but
then I go B4 first
that's crazy but then your Queen's trap
dude
oh my goodness it is trap yes that is so
sad that is actually very sad invitation
yes all right baby he didn't uh he
carried didn't spend too long he just
took the Queens off the board right away
did he curl Queen takes Knight takes and
I'm assuming we just light this position
for white maybe C4 two Bishops yes
what do you mean I'm kind of uh I'm kind
of happy here aren't I if I don't have
made it down the seafo egg file what
about your move yeah so route 28.
that's kind of the the scary for the
mate I have to play B4 only move and now
I'm not sure I take it no no but that's
the thing I don't think I take it I
think I want to go C4 now okay this is a
bit of a relief though that's okay
unless I get made it again I mean I
could be just getting mated he did by
the way take on B4 I I mean Hikaru
didn't spend too much time on C4
strangely enough I think he should have
given that consideration because check
might spoil his Blends his points no
Lavon played Bishop D3 not even a check
wow I would have checked for sure
hoping that I could grab this Pawn on B5
Lavon immediately threatens
The Rook
for and also H7 ponds sometimes yes time
what's going on with our time if you can
show us 6 minutes and 43 seconds for a
Hikaru 6 minutes and 30 seconds for
Lavon so very close very close
in fact identical right now
wow but I think this is going to be an
end game let's go back to that nepo game
just because I have a feeling we're
going to see a resignation
to move E3 we did see a rook D1 check
but not the Rook on B1 it was actually
The Rook on E1 they gave a check King E8
Rook takes on B8 and now a routine the
same move that you recommended yes sir
but I was recommending it with a rook
still on E1 and a rook still on B8 uh I
got a feeling that this is a worse
version
even E2 right now yes right
wait so what if you go E2 check this out
what do you do Maybe
foreign
that is oh sorry no no no E1 check no no
no no no E1 check first and then root to
E3 it's too deep I think that this is
the game because the idea is the moment
I dropped my Rook off yes this diagonal
oops here we go but but yes we're back
to uh losing our Queen
um
E3 E2 looks like one of those things one
of those variations where I have to
calculate tactics and my idea was that
if you to go after e to Queen to E1 and
try to block it like this yes now I go
Bishop to C1
we squint the two or whatever I'm just
trying to have some fun here it's clear
that's all
Nepal's expense to be sure that is uh
they're not my pieces so yes exactly
before I take on B4 and Bishop to D2 and
I go into the end game
that was my idea also and yes but
probably the same game is like the best
nipple can get it right in this position
so let's try to find something better
C7 C6 he just says okay look you're
attacking my Bishop I Define I defend my
Bishop I also uh prepare
ideas of E2 and queen
I mean white keeps all the pluses as far
as I can tell with this move he he gives
nothing a return I this is a very strong
move yeah and really great position for
Shakira I hope computer also likes it I
think E2 was the best winning but I
think that C7 C6 C6 is doesn't spoil
anything the best the best movie the
best movie
because it just I mean you if the best
move is King D3 and I can now play E2
and keep my Bishop defended wow
that is just so and it has the same idea
right outside Bishop F2 unfortunately
doesn't work because of E1 Queen and
then Rook to E3 is isn't there this
though in this position
like uh and Rook E3
and uh just feeling that um
it's not the best
oh my goodness this looks devastating
painful uh many I mean by the way Queen
55 was played Queen to B4 threatening
Queen to D2 Checkmate in one move
by the way Queen B5 on the board Check
Yes only move B4
and Shaq is just enjoying himself right
now Shaq is really just enjoying himself
right now what the game do we know
look at him yeah come on come on dinner
dinner is coming you know
and actually they can't even you know
just finish the game and go together for
a dinner I mean but it also can happen
King C2 okay do we have kingsito is on
the board yes we do okay finally maybe
time to go E2 right
King C2
um this queen was on A1 at the start yes
I just want to point out the obvious
this queen has not moved the whole game
you can't play a game of chess a queen
down I mean it just doesn't work very
well
you know if I'm gonna play C6 defending
the bishop I'm going to play
[Applause]
he gave up his Bishop hi Dairy yes
he's ready
because these uh sets by the way do come
with an extra Queen an extra White Queen
in Mexico
like are you really still playing yes
right uh is there another crunching
movie no come on I have a question if
you take the queen at this moment you're
yes yes so now he does nice
nice okay
I really nice that's a nice one oh what
a finish the under promotion tactic yes
it's cool look at this there's a there's
this nasty check
no no wait a minute yes it is it is the
Checkmate I wanted to show this one
sorry
but that means never well I mean right
now he's succumbed twice in a row yes
he's in trouble he's in trouble but what
about farugia his uh co-leader
that
that was clear anymore to me
for the lead coming into this room
before six and is he nursing an extra
Pawn he was it's gone not anymore yeah
but he's got an idea he's got ideas of
B5 and B4 check followed by Rook takes
B2 but is that enough I mean the bishop
I understand is very strong strong piece
in the end game but if I just go Rook to
D5 followed by Knight to E4
Rook to A5 he played Rook A5 yeah that's
nice I like that move because if we
could still be look at B5 oh if you take
I have A3 oh oh
that's a nice tactic
and if that bomb gets to A2 people are
gonna ask oh my God it's easy to to miss
right but what a problematic guys
because now I imagine it's going to be
met by Bishop to E5
no but you know what the problem is what
I can go A3
what A3 followed by B4
so that's and that's going to create
position before right yes I take on A3
well then I go and Bishop to B4 I don't
think you're going to be able to stop me
I have a feeling you're used foreign
because when you play the move Rook A5
you think that white just exactly this
moment you think that this move has
solved the problems I'm going to take
this Pawn a king will be safe and I'll
follow it up with a rook check B5 is
really a game changer it's a very
unpleasant surprise like you don't play
Rook A5 if you see B5 right so right he
missed it for sure for sure because
you've got two threats Bishop E5 check
as well as B4 check and what is the
times Anastasia yes what about time I
think it's already everybody's should be
on time pressure right now yes everybody
yes
um let's have a close look at because
you can see from here I think I'm seeing
three yes and I have minutes for Lanier
but guys I have bad news for uh once
again all the gallery fans out there oh
no it does seem like he's in trouble
once again Wesley so well Wesley's got
the central bondu when we left that was
happening but we left it at the bishop
before I'm gonna go quickly through what
happened actually two minutes two and a
half minutes against one and a half
minutes for Gary
and Knight takes Jesus ooh Knight takes
G7 came with
perfect timing
yeah big exchange Sacrifice by Wesley
but
his King is very very safe
well actually that's not completely true
there is ideas of Rook
IE E3 whoa
C3 I like this move actually what if I
go Knight D3 I mean I protect everything
right now Rook to B2 is not coming and
you finally activated my knight
that night on C1 was bothering no one
now it's on I'm a little bit worried
about Gary's position D5 and only 40
seconds for Gary to find a way out I
mean B5 is devastating Queen f8 if I go
D5 the Knight on E6 can't no D5 you have
to sacrifice you have to sacrifice a
full Rook after day five
but wait I've got Queen takes eight five
variations pretty much game over yeah
yeah
and there we see Gary
B3 excuse me
there's a there's a bishop lurking yes
so if Queen takes 94 if
but okay how much material are we losing
for the queen but what if I just take
the easy way out what if I go Queen
takes A5 isn't that enough
so I give you a rook and you take a pawn
exactly
this looks like a hopeless engine
yes I mean now also Rook A8 is a threat
you have to go p8 and then D5 is coming
okay if you need to play Rook V8 it's
not good
that's absolutely right what a pawn
structure
seven protecting against
forgetting about this lurking Bishop yes
but I think D5 but also Knight C5 guys
take on D7 I don't think that's enough
well I can take on G2 thank you I'm I'm
most worried about D5 myself
I think D5 if you take with the Knight
I've got Rook check if you take with the
bishop I can take you want to preserve
control yes in the position yes I like
D5 yeah that's that's a very safe move
still let's check Knight C5 just for fun
25 yes okay yes because he's absolutely
for sure he's checking this too if it's
winning then it's just winning right
right
so you can take you can take my rope I
was planning on taking your Bishop but I
see what you're yes then Knight F6 so
maybe first I have to take the Knight
oops right back here yes Anastasia yeah
this is actually what you know Wesley
when he sees until the end the winning
line normally he can go for it so now
what
takes the night yes exactly and then now
what Bishop is three probably Bishop E3
so like crooked two maybe also Rook to
A1 even though that Rook A1 seems a bit
too passive well I use P3 let's just go
Bishop three
yeah the problem is if you take I can
pin you on the seventh with an immediate
threat I'm gonna take C7 yes or okay
seven look look at this
against that
yes they only move probably with the
idea or Bishop before Rook up three
things are not that easy huh yes oh he
did something different
with the Knight on apartment with the
Rook on Knight H6
wow what a move that's a good find that
was a great find I mean in a desperate
situation he came up with a goodie that
is a good finder even the exchange that
they go for the ending
but unclear right yeah with the Bishops
of opposite color I'm I'm in there the
problem is I think you're losing the F6
Pawn as well exactly that's the problem
I I mean if the H7 Pawn was G7 or yeah
yeah 12 seconds for Wesley ten at the
time guys and he just lost on time in
the previous game yes watch out and D5
he played immediately D5 cutting this
Bishop from Kingston
that is a I don't know maybe beautiful
fans of uh pawns that's a great pawn
shop and the only problem right now can
you find a way to wait to wait for a
white to attack the pawn on F6 with the
Knight and go F5 seconds eight seconds
so come on make a move Knight to EA five
seconds for Gary don't lose on time Gary
Knight B5
I know I know I was Victor corchinoy
second and I tell you he would get into
time trouble in each and every second
96. it was all right it was a heart
pounding uh
Bishop to C5 it's a strange move I like
Bishop C5 because if you allow me to
whoa whoa whoa wait can I take on D6 now
what is Gary doing five Gary is taking
trying to eliminate all the parts yeah
he's trying to Accenture all the Pawns
well I don't think that's going to be
enough guys
Bishop takes D5 I go F4 at four and it's
a Time scramble but now I get the Knight
to E4 to E3 sorry
sorry I'm just going to go back and
forth
okay still 20 seconds it's not so bad
well you can think
the problem is there is no way to get
close to the night and that's a
resignation okay but he tried so hard
yes Wesley with the victory nice fight
well then Wesley what is
your guys okay this is a crazy B5
position game and what a game that was
that move
by the way Peter seems to be winning
against uh Fabiano that's that would be
a huge victory for Peter
that this is our game uh right now guys
as as Ali Reza could uh take the clear
first
in the position in the tournament sulfur
sorry
he is enjoying his extra Pawn it's an
extra Pawn but the king is so weak on A6
that's right
Super Active Pieces by white
five seconds he has to make a move two
seconds two seconds two seconds oh he
set up a nasty trap Knight C6 Rook C5 C5
do that don't do that
yes I was about to say Can Rook G8 just
to take I went whoa King D4
keep contact with the Rook on C5 King D4
G5 what else
oh no time six seconds this kid sees
everything King is that two seconds he
will do something that was on one second
cannot believe it
is he gonna miss it two seconds how much
basically he's not missing it oh he saw
it he saw it she's everything should be
a draw Knight takes F6 check should be a
draw
yes and he goes for it King 35 F5 and
King to E6 it does feel like white is
extremely active but that Rook is going
to go to C7
behind the parts
is very dangerous guys
oh oh Rook to C7 but maybe Rook to B7
wait a minute how do you make any
progress with it exactly with white I
for some reason four seconds for linear
f60 would just take it
keep pushing here we go guys I think
this is winning now yes even though how
do you win it's still not over
because you have to stay on the seventh
rank right
oh G5 and Rook to C7 Rook to C7 that's
his best shot he found it
Lanier yeah we're going to survivors
for his time pressure but he's a great
Blitz player too
I think he improved his position with
this uh maneuver King D5 King E5 contact
with the Rook on F4 King B4
C3 he go he goes Rook takes G7 C3
Rook takes G5
yes
it takes G5 I think this is going to be
yeah
he
realizes that he's
is given uh that's just a draw now now
F6 has to draw Rook C1 what a save
linear is amazing how to save
I tell you he is amazing
yes with one seconds you know I mean
that was crazy guys they're so it's
incredible how much pressure alireza
puts on his opponents by the way there
is a trick King D6 Rook D2 check and
Rook D1 correct
yeah side step the the tricks with every
single move he puts a little bit of
pressure all the way until the end
but they will finish until the end you
know that actually you can offer a draw
here but
you can yes yes they said that during
the technical meeting that it's possible
to offer a job but still players are
playing until the end
yes the the the wonderful Smiles of the
players it's just the relief that they
must feel and also playing King to King
Levon aroniana Carla Nakamura uh who was
Anton well Karma was nursing the
advantage in that Rook ending boy I've
got to tell you Anastasia this these
rounds have been exciting oh I have a
feeling that all games were decisive
even some finished in the draw and we
didn't really get a chance to see it but
the Wesley so Gary Kasparov game
finished in a kind of a very unusual way
in the sense that Wesley had this Pawn
on the f file that Gary couldn't get to
and Wesley could just promote the pawn
of the board King D4 F5 F6 recognizing
that Gary threw in the towel he lost
that game Peter Fiddler our common Coke
yes yes he gets in a victory
and somebody who had a perfect day is
with you Christian
Chuck congratulations a brilliant day
for you at the office describe to us or
your initial feelings right now okay
but I can say I just play Just
uh normally
normally in classical chess I just try
to play interesting chess and try to get
interesting position from opening but
now it's from first move is interesting
position
like much better to play these chess I
mean I just play and what I can say just
good games given that you're such a
creative uh genius do you feel like this
chess 960 helps you gives you an edge
over your opposition given that there's
no Theory
okay I mean of course normally I like to
play these chess and I think it's for me
is very interesting but I don't think
uh
it will be very good to play many
tournaments in this
960 because uh because in our days it's
not easy play normal just how we can
play In classical and the Rapid Release
also in 960 but I love this to play this
Jazz and I have good results I mean I
because I enjoyed from first move to try
to sing everything and for this reason
I just happy to play in this yes Levon
said something very interesting
yesterday he said that in chess 960 with
the black pieces you can actually be
much better after five moves of play
definitely felt it was the case in this
game between yourself and nepo take us
through the game okay I mean first of
all I want to say Leon's obserter right
because I played here in four games and
I won all four games with blacks
only I mean I played in with white not
very good I mean just 50 but I would
like in the the really every game in
with black I mean against there is a
yesterday today against the yarn I think
against Hikaru enough to move five every
time I got Main Street why do you feel
that's the case yeah it's just I think
also same for me I when I played with
white against Fabiana I just got very
bad position from openings because
normally we think like classical chess
we need to get Advanced we need to play
for win yeah with white of course you
need to play for active win but for this
reason it's absolutely different I mean
in in this tip just you need to play
just good moves I mean normal moves not
try to win in a few moves because it's
upset another strategical level he
played very well this uh 1960 but uh
for me is upset different again I I
don't know absolutely good rule is how
to do Castle sometimes
I asked I see when I arbitrus near me I
watch his Aces I can't do it or not
I guess I don't know if I have a place
wrong case he will say play with King
and he's play King I need to raise that
okay not a 100 project because it was
one very funny historic I played in
mines in 960. I played I was in leading
in tournament in last game I played
against grishock but Ops it was same
same in classical chess only rook in A1
in Knight B1 is different 91 yeah and I
tried to play D4 it's D5 C4 C6 Knight
f36 e35 I mean he played classical chess
and I tried to B3 Bishop B2 Bishop A3
change this bishop he B3 he played Queen
Seven defensive I played Bishop B2
Quincy one Bishop A3 I mean I mean I
just pretty Bishop A3 and he'd take in
my bishop and I see not in 19
I was in first place it was draw for me
it's okay for first place and I lose
this game in eight moves I mean
sometimes we could forget it yeah let's
talk about this position particularly
because we saw it on the camera and it
felt like you are enjoying yourself at
this point were you feeling that way
more money we all resign in these
positions of course uh better especially
a little bit I am very tired yeah he
take rookie four I start to calculate E1
Queen maybe bishop B7 he tried to play
check one more check okay I will take
King and I like them okay I am a little
bit tight and I want to go restaurant
yeah I think it's better in one night
yeah it's just to win with check I but
of course I remember this very famous
game against Hikaru in Paris he he
played G1 nice and he lose me it's
inside the G1 Queen yes I mean sometimes
it is it can be very bad I mean you can
play very nice you want to play just the
easy move but after you see it's very
bad but now the king can how is now is
King c193 is made
very nice yes Shaq congratulations uh
brilliant they are the office for you
we're looking forward to see you in the
last day thank you very much actually
thank you very much uh very very nice
3-0 but what games do Anastasia I mean
he was really really entertaining
especially this final uh round game
against nepo and here we are yes
now in Thai for the first place together
with alireza ferruder
wow the leadership keeps changing but
Jan is in clear third with four Bobby uh
three and a half Karo climbing back he
had a much much better day than he did
in the first day uh with a group at
three and a half but I tell you our
Golden Boy Ali Reza is gonna leave St
Louis with good money good memories and
a lot of cash and good mood for sure and
good mood and uh speaking of which he is
with Christian
others are congratulations a good day
for you at the office this was in my
opinion in our opinion the key matchup
between you and Nepal who was just
having a brilliant event after that
point and we got this position it felt
like it's just going to end in a draw
but you are still putting more and more
pressure if you feel like you have a
good chances here yeah no but of course
if he keeps my double pawns it's just
throw he miscalculated something after
Rook F2 yeah just give me seven it's
just look H5 King G6 Rook D6 Rook F6
here ah to F6 yeah to not to put keep
the double pawn and I don't have
realistic chance here you go here yeah
Rook F2
perhaps yeah but now with my rookies
yeah so now I take if you take with the
pawn probably or even worse and then
Rook takes King G6 okay I could play
this for this is just throw versus two
but the pawns are still doubled so yeah
it was okay he messed up something here
it still should be draw but yeah now I
have good chances because my I don't
have those phones so
and uh yeah when did you feel he made
the finals yeah
I think
still okay I think maybe King here oh
2K3 is already a mistake okay three
seconds yeah I should start with check
of course yeah and then I made mistake
Rook A5 check yeah King yet of course
should be winning yeah
but but uh the game is not over yet
right yeah yeah it's rookie five yeah
it's very important only move King to
f4007 yeah
but still I think it's drawn no King G8
after Rook F7 King G8
King E3 uh it doesn't look like dry
anymore
I think it is dry here
let's see okay no no it's six C5 no no
Rook C5
but then who takes A7 look at five King
E4 Rook F6 okay my king is already on
the floor ah okay so I'm getting just
waiting for you
yeah maybe instead of Rook C5 just to
keep maybe yeah because the two versus
one is draw I think so this one's yes
yes two versus one is going to be a
Droid computer is maybe over
exaggerating here because how do we
exchange this Pawn is the question yeah
okay one how could I break it's a seven
King f8 yeah check get the king in
um
okay let's see okay five
we couldn't see how to break here okay
you still have to
let's see rookie one
America seven King G8
yeah there's not a clear path yeah Rook
C7 and King D5 it says okay it should be
winning yeah okay A5 Kings is no okay
five King is six yeah yeah so you have
to go King Rook D1 yeah
and then King goes to B8 yeah okay some
study like uh Victory pastilla right
huge victory yeah of course King G8 was
a mistake King E8 was true yeah
we're seeing you all the time well
actually we're seeing other players
cooperating with uh their teammates
let's say we haven't seen you with
anybody how do you analyze these
positions when you get those 10 minutes
yeah I don't think it's very important
or it's very complicated
I don't think even they sit for 40
minutes they cannot find the best moves
because
the chest that we are playing we are
analyzing for thousand years it's not
even clear what to do first move so I
think it's kind of just for fun they are
doing so but in general I like to be I
like to concentrate before the game so
but okay everybody has different
approach you're just like a quiet mental
space yeah relax before the case it's a
bit strange for me because we are
competitors and they are talking
together it's a bit weird for me but
okay maybe
it's not
very important for them this tournament
I don't know what is the case is it
important for you is the big event for
you yeah in any tournament I play I like
to play my best so otherwise I would not
compete so
um yeah I think I played decent here but
until here but I'm very disappointed
with the last game so
but okay still it's fine they're always
a mess but at the same time he also
pressured all the way until at the end
alireza always competitive always a
pleasure to see you uh playing we'll see
you tomorrow thank you our
congratulations as well Ali Reza I mean
I absolutely agree with them I'd like to
uh but hey you know play your best and
what do players do after they finish a
game
some players
a postmodern this is this looks like the
Wesley so game yes Gary
uh it's nice to see I used to love these
postmortems uh today it's like the
players are asked by the organizers to
count and give a comment to the media or
something
but uh now we don't see these
postmortems as much but we have another
player had a good day great yes we have
Hikaru Hikaru congratulations two and a
half out of three a very good bounce
back day after yesterday's let's say to
tumultuous uh they did you feel that way
as well yeah I mean I did what I did
last time I was here two weeks ago
pretty much started off playing uh
terrible chess and then I found a way to
recover on the blitz after a very poor
rabbit portion I mean this this event
obviously is a lot shorter it's only
three days
um but yesterday was was terrible I mean
I lost two games I shouldn't have lost
uh I I felt like I was overpressing a
little bit too much in both those well
maybe not the on game but I mean at
least in the first game for sure I just
completely overpressed it
um and I lost him a chakra and but then
today I mean I I kind of played
something I think was dubious against
Lenny in this first game this this whole
e495 thing I think he probably could
have played something better and I mean
it's the fact that I was in trouble but
I mean it's very hard because like I
don't know whether I mean I feel like
they're generally two approaches either
you try to be like very solid and place
symmetrical or you try to be very
creative and do something different
um and I I feel like I've been I
basically decided you know what I don't
want to play a normal game it's going to
be chaotic and hopefully I'm not just
losing in the complications
um but like in this first game I think I
was just losing I thought this D5 was
very strong
yeah and then for some reason yeah
Knight D2 and F4 of course yeah well
it's just much better
yeah yeah yeah he didn't do this I mean
I saw this during the game and I thought
this basically forces you keeping the
Knight on it yeah I mean I played E3
after well okay there's no 93 yeah yeah
but I mean ef3 you have three F4 is what
I was going to play but it still it
looks it looks horrible I I don't know
it's only 0.5 or 0.99 only with the only
move space no I mean I was gonna do this
but it just it looks ridiculous I mean
it just looks so stupid
um but hmm okay it's only wow it's not
actually just losing the way I thought
so like I thought it was probably very
bad but I played anyway and then uh
Lenny a I mean I guess this is where I
say it's it's good that um it's good
that I don't play chess professionally
anymore because I feel like Lenny if I
had to say one thing about him I feel
like in the in the last couple of years
in particular he's trying to be too
solid like you've seen it here in many
events like you saw it in the sink
filled cup there were a couple positions
he had great positions and he tried to
simplify uh in the blitz against me he
tried to simplify when he was completely
winning for no reason and in this game
also he tried to simplify like even here
like Knight D5 well first of all go back
so I gambled here because after Quincy
when I take it takes I wasn't sure
whether I should take or not because
basically his Knight B5 here and I think
I'm again yeah yeah this is winning of
course yeah yeah so like I I mean I I so
I kind of like I was using the meta
against them based on what I've seen in
recent times because I I just assumed
okay if he finds 955 but if he doesn't
play an ip5 and he plays the automatic
capture which I kind of thought he might
do based on what he's done recently then
I'm back in the game and then later he
played this bishop D4 move which was
just I mean horrible so that was the
strategy from the beginning take some
risks and basically base your decisions
on the fact that he's a bit reluctant to
take X-ray risks yeah you you've just
seen in a lot of events recently where
he's looking for the simplification even
when he's pressing or potentially
outright winning and so I just thought
I'll do it I mean the tournament's going
terribly so did you feel like you're in
a must win situation in the first couple
of games I mean I wasn't looking at most
when you you just don't want to lose
every game because I mean the thing
that's annoying is so last year when I
played the 960. it was very similar
first game I play shocker also and um
and I think we reached some endgame
where I could have forced to draw on uh
Bishops of Ops color end game instead I
blundered and lost that then I think I
lost in like 10 moves or something to
Shanklin in the second game and I think
I lost Lenny in the third game of the
day so like after that experience last
year I mean I just kind of didn't want
to do the same thing uh and so I was
just just kind of playing I wasn't I'm
not thinking about first place that's
like that happens it happens so that
wasn't my thought at least at the start
of the day but but then I mean the
second game I thought was was very very
good I got a nice big Advantage from the
very start
and that was against Peter oh yes yeah I
mean but this was also very funny so so
like it's very funny because Peter and
Gary analyzing and like when you make a
move and your opponent doesn't move
right away sometimes you just get up go
look at the screen to see what other
players have done and it was funny
because I saw the chakra I had also
played Knight G3 against Gary on another
board and um and both of them were
thinking for like five minutes I think
I'll move one which is pretty pretty
funny and then of course Gary also just
got blown away out of the opening too in
this game against Shaq and and my game
of course I think was just it was felt
very pleasant although I thought there
might have been a computer line if you
go to this position how are you
analyzing these positions for those 10
minutes before I'm not I'm not were you
looking at it what are you analyzing no
no I mean I just don't I don't I don't
want to waste my energy analyzing I
figure I'm just gonna look at it for
five minutes and intuitively try to pick
what I think is the best
um and I think I've done a pretty good
job actually for the most part I mean
this last game was the only one where I
was really kind of confused um that was
the game yeah this game against
um against Sylvanas the only one where I
really was very unsure like I didn't
have any real idea what I was supposed
to play for from the from the very start
just it seemed kind of weird
um
what were the pieces that you were
focusing on improving early on well I
mean there's this thing that I spoke
about I spoke about on my recap
yesterday and I've spoken about it
recently so I had this this something
similar to this against Magnus when I
played him in Norway 2018 where he was a
queen on A1 in The Rook on B1 and I
remember when we looked at the engines
at the time they liked playing like some
of these early A4 some of these early
b4s so it's like the one thing is when
you have the queen to work in the corner
like this sometimes you push now
obviously I don't remember what the
other pieces were but I remember that
was something of a theme so that was one
thing that I thought was maybe you push
push one of those pawns early but uh
yeah B3 or B4 something like that I
don't I don't know I'm probably not here
but it's just one of those things that I
thought me either something like that
but in general I just wasn't sure what I
was doing in this game after F3 yeah I
played F6 and I saw Holly Reza played 97
instead of Essex was also kind of
interesting but
um
yeah and then I was I actually I mean I
was very sad that he took on D5 because
I was really hoping that Lavon would
play D5 Bishop B5 this is what I was
hoping to do but then after D4 wow this
is wow this is actually just winning I
mean I thought I thought the sack The
Exchange Act was very interesting but
wow minus 1.4
are you surprised about the assessments
I mean I I thought I looked interesting
I thought I I didn't think it's probably
worse because I I mean I have this big
pond Center but again and like I'm kind
of shocked this is just yeah it's just
losing wow
no it's just bizarre The Exchange stocks
that is the one thing like exchange tax
seem to be the balance is very different
it seems like a 960 than a regular chess
um but yeah Lavon didn't do this and I
thought it was just better
um throughout the game but I think You
Were Somehow yeah I mean I got the
center and that's all that mattered but
but somehow I couldn't
I mean I thought I thought what I did
was very very principled here with B5
and then yeah he took place this
perhaps came to B7 was that was somehow
working that was the move we wanted oh
another one 95 or K7 yes Rook eight
assassins said
[Music]
wow okay
but uh allowing the queen on B6 is no I
mean somehow yeah but also I mean
there's yeah Knight A3 and C4 I guess is
winning uh
yeah but I mean this one's also kind of
hard to play because now I can go Knight
B1 and there's I mean at least at least
without like an hour on the clock it's
kind of hard to assess this as being all
like all that great
um yeah I got this end game and then I
mean I don't know if I was supposed to
Sack or not I mean
here okay so it's okay I feel very good
okay I feel validated that I sacked
because I mean the thing is like I
didn't want a sack but I wasn't really
sure how I'm gonna get an end game where
I'm winning I thought like Rook A2
rookie six on Rook D6 thing for example
and I didn't see it and I mean even King
C5 I thought there was a trick to him
King C5
was it Bishop no Bishop E4 I can take no
no I can take the Rooks or the kimurons
but there was something I saw here was
it rookie uh Rick d1's also move okay
but
yeah I mean I just I wasn't sure about
this than I thought Rook D3 I could
never lose so it makes sense and if he
plays the wrong way I definitely am
winning so I thought there was Zero risk
um but I thought Lavon played this very
well actually
um yeah rookie eight and yeah it's a
real tragedy that Bishop A3 doesn't work
[ __ ] better is what I wanted to play
this is my initial idea because white
goes Works CCA for example
oh no apparently I'm just a bad chess
player I thought I could play wait why
does rp2 not win
King C1 ah because I saw it because I
saw King A1 Rook C2 which I think is
just winning yes because then I have
Rook C1 and B2 with the fork and yeah it
seems like okay maybe not maybe I'm just
a terrible chess player again
uh cause there's rookie 400 K8 okay yeah
I didn't try to go through it yeah yeah
I didn't see it so actually what I saw
during the game was instead of this I
thought that he could play um if you go
yeah like if you go back to King A1 or
go back to sorry yes um go back one more
so no no go back instead of Rook C8
yeah so the line that I saw was rookies
Rook C3 and then I thought Rook B2 King
A1 B4 but then then Rook cc8 it's a draw
um that's why there's no more uh before
square footage yeah exactly so this is
what I saw and I thought it was address
and I then I played Rook D2 but I think
Lavon just played it very very well I
mean I thought what he did was correct
yeah yeah
I mean sometimes you can only tip your
hat
um
yeah and it didn't seem like the balance
yeah because I mean again there's I got
I got it says Rook pawn and game but it
was never never quite there so it's a
little bit disappointing not to win this
one um during the position I had but
again it was messy and uh it's still two
and a half a good day still within
Striking Distance to the leaderboard
well I mean I guess I do play alireza so
I guess if I I've beat him up I mean who
cares I mean the thing is you just try
to you try to play good shots and it's
very unpredictable too because like the
opening decides everything if you get a
good position it's very easy to play I
mean it's a lot of fun you're just
enjoying it like the Civil game but if
you get a bad position right away it's
very I mean you're just like why am I
playing 960 instead of playing uh
playing normal chess I'd much rather
just Blitz out 20 moves of theory
um so it cuts both ways but uh again at
least today I I thought I played pretty
well I thought I calculated well I think
my time usage was much better than
yesterday and it's it's all very good
you gotta go give your rest we'll see
you tomorrow thank you congratulations
to you here for a very very impressed
day two and once again Anastasia our
kind of standings yeah look how tendings
are leading right now during the lead
yeah four and a half not bad at all then
she follows them with four points out of
six
and half points Wesley saw three and
then linear has two points ether won the
game so he has one and a half points
Gary Casper is on the last place
struggling the four out of six would
actually be very nice but it was four
out of four suddenly the four out of six
doesn't look that good does it Christian
absolutely I have to say a very
disappointing day for a nepo for sure
started off blasting with that important
victory in round number one but after
that I mean that game against alireza
was so crucial also for Ali Raza and oh
my goodness don't show that come on yeah
so and you guys call yourselves
professionals I am a really really
disappointed with you guys has been
winning every single tournament in St
Louis since he arrived here I assume
that at some point
yeah somebody should have been with
farooja on this one I mean he's just
been he's just been superb Anastasia
let's face it he's been undefeated I
couldn't imagine that he will win this
event though also but our ultimate moves
yes now this here actually from version
picked up Hikaru Nakamura even though
Hikaru said himself he is a really not
great player yes a couple of times not a
great player not a great player it's
just not it's just not very very very
good uh he's wrong he is a great player
and we enjoy uh watching his games final
thoughts at this uh very cool tournament
uh day two a very cool tournament and
very competitive tournament as well we
we can see even the sixth place right
now is within Striking Distance from
first place three and a half compared to
four and a half so this is definitely
going to be hotly contested in the final
day and we're going to be here to call
all the action I'm looking forward to it
guys absolutely and Anastasia once again
it was great
having you uh on set you promise to come
back tomorrow I do
it's a guarantee tomorrow this is
wonderful thank you so much for sharing
your day with us join us tell tell all
your friends where you've been hanging
out and we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited